okay
what's up peeps
what's up everybody
how's the herb about it doing and
everybody in the club get tipsy I don't
even know that's uh praise anymore but
uh
YouTube's telling me to insert ads
to spam you guys with ads
but we are not going to do that
uh okay how's everybody doing
um so here is here's here's the deal
right here is the the situation that we
are currently dealing with here um
Marvel Studios has decided not to live
stream d23 for reasons it makes sense to
nobody but themselves uh so the best we
have is Twitter right now and uh as you
guys can see from our Twitter feed uh
there's
somebody speaking in Spanish no clue
what they're saying but there's Kevin
feige and there's uh
Elizabeth Olsen so we know they're going
to be there today probably I don't know
they exist in the MCU
but how's everybody doing how you guys
doing how's everybody uh everybody was
the audio good does the audio sound good
right we have our uh you just got two
ads I promise it wasn't me I didn't I
did that during the comments explain
stream when I was doing a test stream I
was doing a q a and um
I uh I I turn around and like and
literally just like inserted an ad by
accident and like 50 people just
vanished from the stream and I was like
because I was like did I just put an ad
in and like 50 people disappeared from
the stream and I was like yep I just put
an ad in like that's that's what happens
ads kill audience retention so kind of
wild uh audio is Chris the audio sounds
good awesome if you guys look to the
chat you guys will see Tony TC does
comics and you will see Alex Tony and
Alex say hi they are our moderators for
this stream and uh I will be keeping you
all company as we run over the various
bits of news that we get from d23 here
in about 30 minutes and uh I will be
making sense of all of it you know
because I have my theories and uh one of
my theories
what are my theories ever wrong
I got an ember mug
battery's dead I don't know what the
point was of buying a mug that can keep
itself warm if I never charge the damn
thing so it can do its job but uh yeah
so the streams if the stream's at 240p
that's probably on you
um
the stream should be really good for
everybody right everybody running 1080p
everybody's showing 1080p I'm showing
1080p so
uh yeah
so what are you guys excited for for d23
I guess that's my question right what
are you excited for for the
announcements coming out of d23 today
what's the one thing you want to see the
most that's that's the question that's
the question what's the one thing that
you want to see the most coming out of
d23
that's what I want to know
yeah Disney and d23 are live streaming
but they're not live streaming the panel
the Marvel Studios panel
you like the office yeah I love the
office what's in the mug
concoction of things that keep me awake
no it's just coffee I'm a coffee addict
so Deadpool 3 The Fantastic Four
Doctor Doom you want to see the Doctor
Doom casting okay here's a question
here's a question here's a question I
want to see this right if this is if
this is what you want I want you to type
yes in the comments if this is what
you're looking for
if you want to see Dr Doom announced at
d23 type yes in the comments
type yes in the comments say yes Rob yes
oh man
the Deadpool musical oh we totally
forgot to set up and set up like a music
playlist
uh we totally forgot to set up a music
playlist for the for the live stream we
literally have no music going in the
background
which I feel like is uh is not
that great of a thing
that's kind of an issue honestly I don't
even know if I can record desktop audio
on the Mac actually I think I can but it
has to be iOS 13 or older and I think
I'm at like 12.5 but we got a thousand
people watching so I think I think it's
all enough and honestly I think we can
keep ourselves hype with the amount of
with the news and everything that's
going to be coming out so yes absolutely
you guys want to see Doctor Doom okay
okay
here's another question
here's another question
if you want to see She-Hulk season 2
announced at d23
yes
that's gonna be quick to chirps people
and there's gonna be cricket chirps
nobody wants to see She-Hulk season two
She-Hulk doesn't even want to see
She-Hulk season two so
but yeah do I think they'll do a blue
Marvel movie honestly no I don't think
they do I think that if they do uh blue
Marvel content Tony thank you for the
Super Chat man uh Tony's excited for the
stream thanks bro uh no everybody's like
no
nobody wants to see She-Hulk season two
announced
that's got to be rough
but
um people are saying yes
people are saying okay so people are
saying yes they want to see they want to
see She-Hulk season two no she holds she
hopes not that too let's talk about
She-Hulk for a second right while we're
waiting for for d23 to kick off let's
talk about She-Hulk here for a second
so honestly I have no gripes about
She-Hulk um it doesn't tie into anything
and to me that's what's really most
disappointing about the show is you get
cameos but there's no like it's it's not
as though like she's working on legal
stuff like there's a post credit scene
where she's working on legal stuff and
Kang's just hovering outside of her
window like yes in like five years my
movie will be here and I will conquer
the Multiverse it's not really anything
like that right you know it's it's
nothing along those lines
um but I kind of wish it did have a
little more that tied into the MCU
outside of like a few cameos that being
said it's just designed to be a
standalone Kevin Peterson thank you for
the Super Chat man for a buck thank you
home slice you're awesome
but uh okay so so uh
Don Helm 20 bucks holy cow She-Hulk
season two yes okay yes thank you for
the for the super chat
um She-Hulk can definitely get better
uh Ryan Gosling is Johnny Blaze ooh but
nonetheless yeah so
um so yeah you know it's
it's not a bad show it's just it's
Standalone and I kind of want to see a
little more where it had some other
stuff involved in it outside from just
the Standalone content but let's see
what other people are talking about here
oh Deadpool 3 is currently trending
what's the latest on Deadpool 3. it's
rumored that the official title for
Deadpool 3 will be announced at Disney's
d23 Expo this Saturday Okay so uh that
was yesterday that was the X-Men updates
from yesterday so that's not really new
um okay so here's a question if if we
were going to see
Deadpool like the Deadpool title
announced how do you guys feel about
Deadpool kills the fox verse for like
Deadpool 3 and literally the plot of the
movie is just Deadpool killing the
entirety of every like everybody in the
fox universe and then at the end of the
movie
he just leaves and goes over to the MCU
what do you guys think
[Laughter]
what do you think
um Edmark Chico General G Nova thank you
uh thank you home slice okay so the
Marvel Studios panel officially starts
at about 23 minutes it starts at 11 A.M
my time 10 a.m Pacific time and that's 1
p.m eastern time I think
um so Gabriel Ramirez thank you uh Carlo
Malika seven dollars in Canadian coin oh
blue Marvel TV show
um a blue Marvel TV show okay so here's
what I think they're gonna do
and honestly I'm not even against this I
think for new characters that are
getting introduced to the MCU not
everybody but the ones that would be
important enough are popular enough to
to have their own movie but they don't
know exactly how that movie is going to
perform they'll get a TV show that's one
of the reasons why I'm on the fence of
the idea of Wolverine getting a TV show
when the X-Men are rolled over into
Disney plus into the MCU
because Wolverine's popular enough that
like on Marvel Studios Wolverine movie
is gonna make bank right that's gonna
make probably a billion dollars right
it's gonna be another billion dollar
film that the MCU does right I mean when
it comes to somebody like Wolverine it's
a license to print money right
um because people just people want to
see it but with with somebody like blue
Marvel I don't know that a movie about
him would would fare as well wait I
don't know if it would do as well so he
would probably end up getting a TV show
so yes I'd be down with a blue Marvel TV
show
um
you hope they announced Nova Richard
Ryder uh I'd be down with that I mean
I'm more for Sam Alexander than Richard
writer but you know I'd be okay with
that uh Deadpool maximum effort yes
right Deadpool maximum effort uh that
would be cool like I know that's
supposed to be the title that's the leak
that is supposed to be the title but you
know we'll we'll find out
um
you love the Deadpool movie idea Alex
Lewis uh will I be at New York Comic Con
I'm not 100 sure yet I have booked my
hotel I booked my flight
um I do have a press pass to it but I
may end up canceling all that I do want
to go to Boston October 9th through 16th
so you know I may I may not go to New
York Comic Con I'm not 100 sure I'm kind
of conned out at the moment to be honest
I've been conning too much
I've been counting Non-Stop
um
let's see uh
she hooks a great show if you just
forget it's in the MCU I guess
hmm
uh you will get a black bull TV show
just for me thank you please don't oh by
the way I forgot to open this stream
this is your reminder everybody out
there this is just a reminder that
Blackboard sucks don't forget Black Bolt
is garbage he is literally walking trash
walking refuse in the MCU
Jeremy Allen White for Wolverine and
Hugh Jackman for Doctor Doom what do I
think by the way Kenny merota thank you
um
I want to see Hugh Jackman come back to
be honest with you guys uh I do want to
see Hugh Jackman return I I I think he'd
be it'd just be great to see him if at
the very least okay you know what would
be cool you know what would be awesome
they could give Hugh Jackman a cameo in
a wolverine film just call it like Old
Man Logan right because here's here's
the thing okay so so here's my thought
process on the X-Men and here's then the
whole reason why or the whole reason for
this is based off of off of Marvel
Comics
so
the prevailing rumor is that we may not
get anything regarding the X-Men
announced in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
during d23 and like no solo film or
anything like that now that's just
that's that's the running Theory people
have there are just as many theories
saying we're going to get like a full
X-Men announcement and like it will like
they're gonna do like the whole X-Men
treatment which they didn't do a San
Diego Comic-Con but
what I think might happen here is I
think that we're going to be looking at
a situation where if the X-Men do appear
they may just show up in secret Wars
because one of the things to know is is
superheroes like Titania if I remember
correctly I know for sure it was Spider
Woman Julia Carpenter the first Spider
Woman
um there were characters that Marvel
just introduced in secret Wars they just
appeared there and then you actually got
their origin story in secret Wars like
in terms of how they got there so like
Julia Carpenter spider woman's a really
good example of that how crazy would it
be if they say nothing about the X-Men
and then they just appear in secret Wars
right like Avengers Secret Wars they're
just there like from a different
Universe because and here's the reason
why
so when Marvel Comics when it came to
Secret Wars because I imagine the secret
Wars film is going to be based off the
2015 story arc by Jonathan Hickman so
the way that played out is is you
basically we have about about 19 minutes
until d23 kicks off oh by the way I need
to get the charger for my laptop uh
because my laptop is not charging right
now and I got 26 left
um
which is a problem so give me one second
guys
come on
foreign
okay
how many oh wow we didn't even lose our
stream holy cow I figured like most of
the stream would have just been like
peace they would have just bailed
okay uh
I uh
forgot
where I put my charger for a minute
there
there we go we keep a professional here
at geek culture explain we forget our
chargers and and all that stuff but
we're back now I know I know uh Tony's
my social media guy I bet he was just
absolutely freaking out right he was
just like oh my God you know
oh my goodness but um but yeah so anyway
so back on track so my idea was this
when it comes to the X-Men in in secret
Wars the original Secret Wars 1984 they
would just they just introduced some
characters Julia Carpenter Spider-Man I
think Titania was like that things along
those lines
in the secret Wars 2015 story you had
the main secret War Story itself right
and then you had additional titles that
kind of circled around right it was
called like it was basically in a place
called battle world the stories dealt
with things like War zones and stuff
like that you had a story called Old Man
Logan now Old Man Logan was a story that
was actually a continuation of the
original Mark Miller Old Man Logan story
where basically that version of
Wolverine ended up as part of battle
world and the way the battle world was
set up is you had god king Doom who
basically ran everything but he ended up
just kind of skipping around and jumping
around and actually leading his domain
and so on but through that story through
like I think it was The War Zone story
whatever it was through that Old Man
Logan story from Secret Wars he made his
way into the main Marvel Universe and
that's how you ended up getting
basically Old Man Logan in Marvel Comics
until they brought the original Logan
back and then killed Old Man Logan off
it was literally a story called The
Death of the death of Old Man Logan or
something along those lines anyway the
important thing here is I know it's dead
man Logan
um
but the important thing here yeah the
announcements start at 11 A.M so about
12 minutes
um what you could do is you could
literally do an Old Man Logan story
which is kind of like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is send off to
Wolverine here's the question that I
would ask here right do we need a
send-off to Hugh Jackman right do you
does the does the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as much as we would love it do
we really need Hugh Jackman so that's
that's my question that I have for you
guys do you want to see Hugh Jackman or
are you ready to see somebody else play
the role of Wolverine in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right let me know I'm
just kind of curious so
uh what is Rob's favorite superhero my
favorite superhero of all time is
probably the the one that I love the
most is Superman
um the story in terms of like origin
that I love the most is blue Marvel blue
Marvel has the greatest superhero origin
ever
I look like Old Man Logan yes I'll pop
my claws on everything
[Laughter]
you're fine with a new a new world yeah
see that's that's kind of what I thought
right like Logan the Logan film was the
send-off
for Wolverine right it was a send-off
form so we don't necessarily need him
anymore
um where do I uh where do I think we'll
see Maestro in the MCU okay so I think
the Marvel Cinematic Universe teased
Maestro Hulk so those of you guys who
don't know who for you know what let me
ask this question because I love I love
the audience engagement
if you know who Maestro Hulk is type yes
and I feel like a lot of you guys come
from Comics explains you might already
know but if you know who Maestro Hulk is
type yes that way I know whether or not
I need to explain it or not
uh We're Not Gonna See Katherine carrot
that person's definitely a Comics
explained fan
Hugh Jackman will always be Wolverine um
I I actually do miss Ohio to be honest
with you guys
um Hugh Jackman will always be Wolverine
and so far as uh people are saying yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
okay so most everybody knows who Old Man
Logan is thoughts on King replacing the
beyonder in secret Wars I'm actually
perfectly okay with that I have no
qualms with that
um Hugh Jackman got a send-off it was
called Logan let us have a new one
Norman Reedus is my pick you know what
stick see I'm I'm on the I'm I'm
actually on board with that I am on
board with saying okay like Hugh Jackman
had his time it's Logan it was a
wonderful time we all loved it
um but it's time for it's time for a new
person to play Wolverine and I think the
Marvel Cinematic Universe feels the same
way I think they very much feel the same
way they're ready for a new Wolverine so
I miss Ohio because of the greenery and
because there was there was a lot to do
um a lot more than there is to do around
here so I just wasn't in the best mental
state to be able to enjoy it fully but
that's that's not a topic for this live
stream so
um
Anthony Starr as reverse flash yes I've
been advocating that for a long time
Anthony Starr homelander he should
absolutely play reverse flash in the MCU
so uh Kanye West is blue Marvel no only
if blue Marvel's gonna go crazy and
start spouting all kinds of crazy stuff
on on
what not
um Squirrel Girl maybe like a end credit
scene and Thunderbolts or something I
want to see squirrel girl beat up Doctor
Doom that's what I want to see squirrel
girl fighting Doctor Doom would be
hilarious Henry Cavill is Doctor Doom
God Emperor Doom you think would be the
best movie okay I don't think Henry
Cavill would uh the rumor for d23 for
the announcements is that Henry Cavill
is going to be playing
um Hyperion in the MCU I don't know how
accurate that is but that's the ongoing
rumor
again I don't know if that's absolutely
true or not so
take it for what it's worth but
uh Danny DeVito for Wolverine no
um
let's see uh you don't know who writes
it here but
uh
but that but my idea that Edward Norton
should play
Maestro is just amazing yeah Edward
Norton is Maestro Hulk would be cool I
would love Edward Norton as Maestro Hulk
okay
um how many here do not know who Maestro
Hulk is that's probably the question
that I should have asked if you don't
know who Maestro Hulk is type no that I
think it'll be easier to discern that so
is hyperion good or bad Hyperion it
really depends on which version you're
talking about so there's what's called
King Hyperion which is a version of
Hyperion from an alternate reality where
he basically killed all the cosmic
entities and he killed all the
superheroes on his Homeworld
and then he ended up in the mar the main
Marvel Comics universe and then he
fought blue Marvel and blue Marvel beat
the hell out of him so that was an
amazing story but
um
but yeah so uh I'm I'm not I'm not 100
sure
um
I mean if we go with like Marcus Milton
from earth13034 uh that is hyperion the
more recent version of Hyperion who
feels more like Superman than anything
else
so okay so those guys who don't know who
Maestro Hulk is and Maestro Hulk he's a
version of The Incredible Hulk that's
probably one of the coolest
so Maestro Hulk oh that you know what
that's what we should have done Tony
that's that's what we should have done
was was okay you're Simon Tony from here
on out over the course of the Stream
is is I'm going to say Tony I need you
to pull the audience to see if we have
an answer to a question you know to find
the answer to this question and we can
we can use the poll to determine who
knows what about about what so 72 say
yes 28 say no
yes okay cool so for those of you guys
who don't know who the Maestro Hulk is
the Maestro Hulk's probably one of the
absolute best uh best versions of the
Incredible Hulk
um
yeah I'm actually I'm supposed to get um
I'm supposed to get like lunch or
something like that with Ryan the next
time I'm in New York uh probably maybe
for for New York Comic-Con but he and I
are supposed to get lunch somewhere
um who do you want to see as Dr Doom I
would love Giancarlo Esposito or Gary
Oldman might be a good Doom I still say
silly and Murphy it's a little weird to
see him as Doom but the more I think
about a personality wise the more you
could do it so in in Age of Ultron we
still never found out right so getting
back to the Maestro Hulk in Age of
Ultron we never found out what it was
the Incredible Hulk saw right we know
what black widows saw we know what Thor
saw we know what Captain America saw we
never found out what the Incredible Hulk
saw because we never found out what the
Hulk saw at least the the option to open
for us to find out who the Hulk is right
for us to be able to see who the
incredible or who what it was the Hulk
saw my thought is Bruce Banner saw
himself becoming Maestro now Maestro is
a version of The Incredible Hulk from
the future where the world had basically
found itself engulfed in nuclear war uh
more recently they wrote a story called
Warren packs about Maestro Hulk which
basically covers how things transpired
like how the Incredible Hulk went from
being the Incredible Hulk to becoming
the Maestro Hulk so like fighting
Hercules and things like that it was one
it was a really really cool story that
Marvel did but the thing about this is
that if that happens he basically ends
up creating a city called uh called
oh my God what was the dystopia that's
what it was I think it was called
dystopia uh he basically ends up
creating a city where what's left of
humanity largely operates under him and
he just becomes a dick like he just
rules with an iron fist I mean it's it's
crazy but he's ridiculously strong like
Professor Hulk showed up to the Maestro
hook timeline and Maestro Hulk beat the
hell out of him he broke his neck I mean
he absolutely crushed Professor Hulk it
wasn't even close so it was It was kind
of nuts but uh that's basically Maestro
Hulk so
yeah five minutes until the d23 panel
all right we need to uh
uh we need to find we need to get
Twitter going back again all right so uh
let's kind of see what's going on here
let's see what bits of news we're
getting five minutes until the panel
starts you got I mean that's the thing
man God I really wish they were live
streaming it I really wish they were
showing this panel because it would be
God it would be amazing to be able to
see it
um yeah let's see what kind of news they
have coming I love this right here
uh Marvel Studios just announced Wong
coming to theaters in the summer of
2024. here's a question would you watch
a Wong solo film
would you watch a movie about Wong by
himself that's that's my question to you
guys would you watch a Wong solo film
because I would I would watch the hell
out of a Wong solo film I feel like it'd
be amazing I would love that movie or
like a long solo series like a Solo TV
series I would watch that because Wong
is a fan favorite people love Wong right
Wong's amazing
what if they use America Chavez this
Hank pin and she is uh she is the one
who finds the beyonders what's causing
the incursions that's entirely possible
now the question is is she gonna find
like if it's the beyonders in Avengers
Secret Wars
is she gonna end up like people say no
yes
um
if they do that is America Chavez gonna
discover the beyonders the same way that
like Hank Pym did because for those of
you guys who never read the original
Secret Wars
when Hank Pym finally finds the
beyonders right the white Lords of wild
space when he finally finds those guys
it's it's insane like he basically like
he just happens to come across them
right like he just happens to come
across them and they're annihilating all
the cosmic entities across the
Multiverse they're killing them all
eternity Infinity Master order Lord
Chaos and so on and so forth and then
you end up getting to the point where
they basically show up and they face off
against
um what is it I'm sorry the The Living
Tribunal shows up and they kill the
Living Tribunal so like it's it's one of
those things where like literally Hank
him like after he's done telling a story
he's like yeah guys that's what we're
dealing with there's nothing we can do
there's nothing we can do to stop that
level of power like the best we can hope
for is that we make it out in one piece
but like that's it I would love to see
that kind of a thing but I would love to
see that that whole situation unfold so
um
do I think we'll ever get Cloak and
Dagger we got a cloak and dagger TV show
didn't we
didn't we get a cloak and dagger show
I'm not 100 sure but I'm pretty sure we
did I'm pretty sure we got a cloak and
dagger four okay we got two minutes two
minutes two minutes two minutes dos
minutos dos minutos
okay
um
all right
make sure that we keep our attention on
everything going on here by the way guys
by the way guys if you are new to the
channel make sure you guys hit that sub
button make sure here's what I want
everybody to do I want everybody to drop
a like on this stream just hit the like
button this that's that's what I want
everybody to do hit the like button on
this stream and if you're not part of
the channel make sure you sub to the
channel so we we we we are oh my God we
bridged the gap between people who know
nothing about comics and people who love
the the Marvel Cinematic Universe kind
of and we come up with theories and
stuff like that so
um
let's see uh a Gambit origin movie We
were supposed to get that like years ago
we were supposed to get that years ago
and like we never got it like it never
happened uh okay they're usually pretty
good about starting on time right so if
they're like 11 A.M like it happens at
11 A.M but it also kind of depends
sometimes so
yeah I don't know it really depends on
on what's going on
Sue Storm Casting revealed what
there's no way they cast season are they
starting off with a Fantastic Four
no way
lucasfilm Marvel Studios 20th century
Studios
uh ready for cast announcements
celestial's end of time I guess that's a
leak
that's not really an actual thing
God they need to hurry up with this man
dude I'm so hyped about this
is taking on the stage right now and
reminding us today that it won't be live
streamed okay yeah they're not live
streaming it
we will be live streaming live live
tweeting those notifications okay that's
that's that's exactly it man that's
exactly it right there this this video
right here that's everybody right now
that's everybody
that's 100 everybody
yeah man
would you guys watch that would you guys
watch a movie called [ __ ] and balls from
Marvel Studios
would you like Tony make a poll on that
Tony make a poll I want to see how
people respond to it would you watch a
movie called [ __ ] and balls from the
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I absolutely would I think that would be
hilarious
that would be absolutely hysterical
come on man
we will begin momentarily announcement
oh God come on
yes this yes Matt Murdock
Matt Murdock yes you're going to be in
She-Hulk I'm willing I would bet all the
money in my pockets so all the money in
your pockets that he's gonna be like a
post-credit scene in the She-Hulk show
I mean it's gonna piss off the world if
that's the case
it's going to make everybody so mad if
that's the case
it's time it's time nothing's really
coming out okay let's see what Marvel
Studios Marvel Studios has to say
uh
where's that even
uh
okay yeah nothing's really nothing's
really coming out yet okay
yeah I know he's in the trailer a ton
I'm messing around with you guys
so
face us
uh
okay let's let's get back to this
why are so many of these in Spanish
why are so many of these in Spanish
like I can't like I can't even
understand half of these
we should just settle on a person who
likes speaks English and just go with
their updates
and call it a day see like this this is
all in Brazil why is this all in in
Spanish why are so many of these in
Spanish I don't understand what's going
on is it like a setting is it like a
geographic setting right like does
Twitter think I'm in Spain or Brazil
somewhere in Latin America Portuguese
Portuguese okay
uh Visa Mexico Rob
Speedy Gonzalez I mean Marvel's been
doing Star Wars for a while Marvel's
been doing Star Wars comics for a long
time
as Portuguese not Spanish see that shows
you how little I know about about the
Marvel cinemat or about uh foreign
languages
people are like that's that's Portuguese
my dude I'm sorry guys I'm sorry
uh time to plug nordvpn nope this is not
a brand integration live stream nope
that's not gonna happen
um but if it was a brand integration
oh man okay uh
use that d23
it's very blue in there oh my God
Fantastic Four announcement
enjoy the show
help prevent prior event piracy
Marvel Studios just announced Ned coming
to theaters okay there's no way that's
true
it'd be funny if it was
it'd be hilarious if it was
okay we're we're at Marvel Studios let's
go back to d23
the Blurred cave yeah that's Ernie
uh
uh a d22 hold on what
oh okay
so yeah it's not an actual stream I was
like what they literally just said they
weren't streaming
Matt shackman director to reboot the
Fantastic Four oh my God
okay that's cool I guess
tales of the Jedi okay so we kind of
knew tales of the Jedi was coming right
like that's not really a new thing like
we knew tales of the Jedi was coming
like that's not a whole new thing
the Marvel panel is about to start
oh Eric they got to go to they got to go
to d23 damn it
Eric Voss and those guys got to go to
d23
yeah like we didn't even we didn't even
book tickets or anything like we didn't
even try to go
uh
Matt shackman shakeman shackman director
of the Fantastic Four what else is mad
okay
um what else has Matt done what else has
that guy done
uh discussing film is a good Twitter
account to follow for live updates
oh they were great during Comic-Con okay
cool let's look up discussing film
let's look at look up discussing
discussing film
tweets
Elizabeth Olsen was spotted a d23 all
right uh
they updated like
20 oh are they I wonder if they're not
there
that's like 37 minutes ago
the real disgusting film are these are
these all oh God I hate those duplicate
accounts
I hate those duplicate accounts man
okay
move they're making a movie about Mufasa
what
that's crazy
all right Marvel Studios let's just
stick with Marvel Studios
Marvel Studio okay after the lucasfilm
announcements the Marvel Studios
announcement will follow okay so right
now they're just focusing on Marvel
Studios
Networks
yeah it is kind of weird to see the
Marvel Studios 20th Century Fox logo
that's kind of wild
okay so I have you guys have you guys
heard the rumors about that about Seth
Rogen playing playing Ben Grimm in the
MCU have you guys heard about that
young scaramufasa yeah I'm totally down
with that
all right dude Mufasa was great man
everything the light touches foreign
well what's that over there dad
that's the south side of Chicago Sun
you must never go there I wonder how
people would have reacted to that if
Mufasa had been like that's the hood son
you must never go there like I'd be
curious how people would respond to that
I think it'd be funny as hell so
yeah it was a it was a 4chan leak so
like I said I mean you can't take it as
an absolute truth
but yeah I really want to see John
Krasinski return as Reed Richards all
right let's go back to Twitter real
quick let's see what Twitter's got
uh morbius Stars Jared nobody cares
about more of you wait a minute wait a
minute Fantastic Four
okay they're just they're trolling
everybody now the cast of morbius has
been cast for The Fantastic Four no way
no way
that's never gonna happen not a chance
uh the Marvel Studios and lucasfilm
panel has started yeah yeah we'll be
posting live updates throughout the
panel all you know what let's start with
geeks of color let's let's jump into
them
let's see what all they have
uh
tweets
okay
they're kind of just saying the same
thing
so nothing really new there uh
yeah I don't know why all of these are
in Portuguese like
does my Twitter app think I'm in
Portugal
right like do I need to
does it think I'm in Brazil or something
like that do I need to like adjust that
I mean internet educate me I'm an old
man right I don't I don't know how the I
don't know how to tweet books and the
the mystograms and so on I don't know
how those things work the my talks and
the Tweet books and so on
um
but yeah I don't know if it just if it
just thinks that I'm in like Brazil or
something
um
yeah the the okay so those guys who
don't know um the reason we're doing
this as opposed to like actually
watching a stream is that Marvel Studios
like the the Marvel Studios d23 panel is
not being live streamed to anybody if
you're not there you don't see it that's
just that's literally what it is all we
have are like tweets that's that's
that's all we have
so I am not using a VPN right now uh not
to my knowledge
no there's uh
yeah no I'm not using a VPN so
Twitter from Earth 1610
I'm just seeing like a bunch of the live
tweets are in Portuguese okay that works
I kind of figured that was the case but
yeah lucasfilms first yeah so the way
they're doing this is lucasfilm is doing
all their stuff so everything is Star
Wars related the rumor here and I don't
know how much of this is true I don't
know how much of this is true right so
do not take this as an absolute truth so
if I see you on the internet and you're
like this is happening at d23 Rob said
so in the geek culture explain stream
which you should absolutely be subscribe
to geek culture explain it makes you
guys like this stream uh the rumor for
d23 is that they're releasing the new
Mandalorian trailer for Mandalorian
season three that's the rumor I don't
know how much that is accurate but
that's the rumor so
yeah
lucasfilm 20th Century Fox and Marvel
Studios panel has this begun
wow
so are they doing okay because I don't
know how the d23 panels work in
comparison to like San Diego because in
San Diego at Hall h like everybody just
gets their hour right is what it is
unless you're Warner Brothers and then
you squander your hour but
um
uh we will have the Marvel Studios panel
okay
that place is enormous
God I wish I was there wongers coming
soon
is that oh that's a Sopranos I thought
it was Saul Goodman for a minute there
hold on is that dark side just lingering
in the background
what even
what even
but yeah like we need to start sending
fuel correspondence to this stuff
uh
uh we're minutes away okay like how how
many minutes because I hate it when
people say that they're like we're just
minutes away it's like well how many
minutes 120 you know like it's just like
okay well I mean that's not gonna help
anybody like that's two hours man like I
hate it when people say that I guess
like the the the indication there is
that it's minutes away in so far is like
two or three minutes but like it could
be a lot of minutes you know like like
Bunches of minutes you know like we're
minutes away we're like I could
literally say that at any point in time
but uh it's like we're minutes away so
it's like uh okay super ninja blue stops
spamming discussing film uh if you don't
stop spamming discussing film we're just
gonna kick you out of the chat
um mods keep an eye out for that guy so
um I would say if if like I don't know
how their panels work it's like
everybody gets an hour at San Diego
right a d23 is it just like a gigantic
thing
so
is it just like a gigantic thing
I don't know
it's kind of weird
uh Rob Latin America is the second
biggest audience for MCU stuff behind
the U.S oh that's why I'm seeing a lot
of Spanish and Portuguese okay I didn't
realize it was that popular out in Latin
America
huh
that's interesting
uh
what's up Nick Wilson love you too
uh
uh okay
let's see
I mean we can I mean yeah like I I know
that I'm just saying like like don't
spam discussing film Non-Stop like don't
don't do that continually but okay so
now they're starting to Tweet stuff
Kathleen Kennedy joins the stage at d23
maybe I just clicked on the wrong
discussing film account
um about Andor which releases also
September 21st okay I don't know how I
feel about Andor I'm a little uncertain
about Android I'm excited about it
because it's the first real Star Wars
project that we're getting now that
doesn't involve the Skywalker era right
because as far as I'm aware unless I'm
wrong the the film does not involve the
Skywalker Saga right like uh it doesn't
involve the Skywalker Saga so like
there's no Luke Skywalker there's no
Anakin Skywalker none of that stuff
right like
it's just straight up
um
just straight up like absent all of
those things
um
um
yeah I don't yeah okay that's that's
what I thought people were like I'm
unsure too I mean this will this will be
the reveal of what we get to see I'm I'm
excited about that like I'm hyped about
that
but the thing I'm concerned about is is
it going to be interesting right because
like like Warner Brothers tried that
they released a show called
um it wasn't Candor it was a Candor
um no it wasn't Candor it was
um oh my God what is the name of
Superman's home it's Krypton that's what
it was it was a show called Krypton
which was about the people on Krypton
um but I got board watching so I just
stopped watching it
um it was a TV show yeah I get that but
like I got I got tired of watching it so
I was like man like and so I'm hoping
Andor is not going to be the same way
but
uh there's Ray Skywalker
um when do we get Darth jar jar I don't
know
I don't know so
um
let's see
it in humans movie with Black Bolt no
not a chance why do people keep spamming
me
uh
let's see
they're live streaming oh yeah live
stream on that no so the actual no the
Marvel Studios panel
if they're live streaming it I'd be
curious how there's no there yeah
there's no way that's the case because
like it's not being it's not being
broadcast in any capacity like in any
way
um
okay and or season two is close to
beginning of a while so they already
guarantee a season two
and or overall as a 24 episode spy
Thriller
24 episodes
they better man they better
it better be good right because if
they're investing all this money in a 24
episode series
that's gonna be
yeah if they're investing all this money
in a 24 episode season
and it's not good it's going to be a
colossally wasted 24 episodes
I don't know why they're not streaming
it they're more yeah the Marvel Studios
panel is not being streamed for reasons
it makes sense to nobody but themselves
so
why can't you have geek culture explain
in Swahili why would the why would the
channel be in Swahili
foreign
yeah that's an all-in like that's an
all-in
yeah but I mean if they're yeah 12
episodes per season what they're
building it is like a 24 episode event
right like assuming that it is 12
episodes per season they're building it
is like a 24 which means that season one
is immediately going to spill into
season two so that means that season one
is probably going to end on some kind of
cliffhanger but the plot details of
season one are not going to be concluded
which means they're relying on the
success of season one for season two to
make sense
so that's that's that's where I'm coming
from so it's gonna be one of those
things where it's like because because
it would be it's it's it's the
equivalent I mean okay the MCU was able
to pull that off but the reality here is
every MCU movie is like a standalone
film so it would be like Avengers Age of
Ultron and then like Avengers Age of
Ultron like at the end of the movie
Ultron activates and it's like you gotta
go watch part two to understand what's
gonna happen like that's a big gamble
you know to me like it's just it's kind
of like all right I mean I'm I'm excited
to see it like I'm down for it but it's
kind of like man I don't I don't know
how I feel about that
like
new characters for Andor revealed
are you guys able to see this on the
stream I don't know if you guys can see
the pop-up
but you guys probably can't
but
yeah are you guys able to see that
yeah you got okay cool you guys are able
to see that pop up
okay
cool I just want to make sure it popped
up for you guys so
and or dies on a planet called scarf
[Laughter]
um
will lucasfilm ever make another Star
Wars movie I mean Lucas film is yeah I
mean it's sure I don't see why they
wouldn't I mean
is
Disney gonna make any more Star Wars
content
more Star Wars films again after
episodes seven eight and nine look
here's the thing man people will talk
bad about episode 789 and people will
say they didn't like it and the movies
certainly had problems were the movies
so bad that Disney now considers all of
their efforts and Star Wars films to be
a failure absolutely not and that's
ridiculous to believe that they're
definitely going to make more Star Wars
films
they're definitely going to make more
Star Wars stuff
like that's absolutely going to happen
uh Kyle solar uh teases
that his character and Andor is someone
you'll learn to love or learn to hate
Marvel Studios has just announced a
valkyrie show coming to Disney Plus in
2024. uh okay are both of these Studios
going on to the same like are both their
panels happening at the same time
like are both of them happening at the
exact same time like I mean how's how's
Marvel Studios announcing stuff at the
same time as
uh
the anticipated movie is set to be
released in summer of 2026.
hmm
the studio Showcase of Marvel Studios
lucasfilm and yeah none of this stuff is
being live streamed so
oh it's fake okay cool that's what I
thought all right cool
awesome I appreciate it guys thanks for
looking out with these fake accounts
that exist out there calling them out so
that's perfect
uh
all right we'll just stick with
discussing films since they're the ones
that have they're the ones that are
throwing out accurate stuff so
um Adria arona's Bix has a complicated
uh on-again off-again relationship with
Cassian Andor
in Andor
the the planet named after that guy see
here's the thing my knowledge on Star
Wars is not nearly what it is on Marvel
Comics I'll just give it to you guys
straight but I will give it to you guys
straight like I am by no means razor The
Savage I have arrived I love your videos
it's great to see the stream did you
miss anything exciting no we're right
now we're going through the the they're
having the Star Wars lucasfilm panel
um
when the Star Wars and lucasfilm panel
is over I think it goes into uh
uh the Marvel or I'm sorry the 20th
Century Fox panel and then it goes into
into Marvel Studios
so yeah
uh Star Wars and Marvel are sharing the
same panel um maybe I mean it's kind of
weird I mean how does how is that gonna
work here it uh here it it's Star Wars
we're releasing a new Andor series
Marvel what do you got well thanks you
for the thing here at Marvel Studios we
got this what do you got like do they
like do they like tag team and go back
and forth I got to tell you guys one of
the things I love about technology it's
kind of hot down here I can control the
thermostat from my phone
I absolutely love that
like literally
the ecobee thermostat I can control it
from my phone
uh
and I can set it to cool it's just it's
one of the coolest things and then I can
control my I can control my
Tesla from my phone I'm so add we're
here to focus on Marvel Studios and I'm
showing you guys my ecobee thermostat
from my phone and my my Tesla app on my
car when in the hell even
but uh
but yeah
okay let's see what you guys are saying
let's see what you guys are talking
about
uh what announcement would I be hyped
for like when I get a fight talking
about Superboy Prime like what what
announcement coming from Marvel Studios
would just get me just just turned up
right would just get me excited get me
lit uh
I would say
the face cam stuck uh the FaceCam stuck
it's stuck on your end uh either that or
else
I was just like
does it look stuck
there's a face cam look stuck
um I would be hyped for anything related
to Blue Marvel and I would be excited
for Hyperion
I'm messing with you guys I would be
excited for Hyperion
um Henry cavill's Hyperion would be
absolutely amazing I'd be so excited for
that
I would be so on board with that
I made you guys think I was stuck didn't
I like I was frozen
there
[Laughter]
oh man
yeah I want to see an end I want to see
the the because here's the thing I don't
know
the final trailer for Andor has been
released
the first three episodes okay can we
even play audio on the Stream
foreign
second
let's pop this back up
what in the hell even is that why is it
flickering and going crazy
wasn't doing that a minute ago
foreign
wow
thank you
that looks like it's going to be cool
that looks like it's going to be amazing
yeah that looks like it's going to be
baller as hell
oh it doesn't show the video either it
should show the video oh I probably need
to like move it up
so you guys can actually see it but
um it's and or before or after the
Skywalker I don't know we won't know
until we actually get to see it so
yeah
uh
let's see
a new look at the phase two clone
troopers and Andor
okay so we don't really get like a good
shot of them but we get a decent shot
that's cool
they look good enough
new proposal promotional art for Willow
is anybody excited about the willow film
indoors between episodes three and four
okay
uh
Rob has been announced for Secret Wars
uh
yeah he does die in Rogue one so you
kind of know see that's kind of the
issue of doing like uh of doing prequels
is you sort of know the fate of people
right of like what's going to happen to
them right that's the difficulty of
making like prequel stuff
oh Willow Willow God that was a great
series back in the day it's got a cult
following it's becoming more popular now
than it used to be
but
okay so here's here's a question Tony I
want you to pose this as a question in
the in the in the the chat I want you to
pose as a question how many of you guys
know that we have a Discord server
would you rather have a Wolverine series
or a movie
um if I were going to if I were going to
do a wolverine if I'm going to do
Wolverine I would want to do a series
because it just it it makes it easier to
iron out the plot when you do a series
as opposed to
um as opposed to a movie so I would want
to see a Wolverine series
that's what I would prefer
and then if I were going to do a series
um I don't know what series I would do
I mean there's a bunch that you can do
you can do like Greg Rucker's run you
could do Old Man Logan
um
you could do a handful of different
things
uh
uh let's see oh yeah we did get some
super chats
um what do I want to get announced uh I
want a blue Marvel announcement I want
to I want Henry Cavill to play Hyperion
I want that announced Deadpool 3 I
definitely want announced
uh yes those are those are the
announcements that I won just off top of
my obviously X-Men everybody who knows
me knows I'm a huge X-Men fan so
obviously that
um do I feel like John Krasinski will be
announced at 616 Mr Fantastic see I want
him to be but Spider-Man no way home
established that not every Peter Parker
looks the same which means that they can
just cast like different people to play
different uh different things
uh content episode three to four is
being so overdone you just can't get
excited for any content in that area
anymore yeah um people everybody's just
kind of ready to to move on past the
Skywalker Saga so
um
but yeah so okay let's uh let's jump
back into Twitter so
um the link to our Discord which
actually you know what let me fire up
let me fire up Discord here
and I will send you guys the link to our
Discord server so you guys can go hang
out
um
uh see
actually I can just type it in the chat
uh
that is a link to our Discord server
uh
yeah 6 500 people watching the stream is
pretty baller
yeah that's pretty badass
uh oh my head admin actually sent me a
DM and he was like you should plug the
Discord
so
that is a link to our Discord server so
so go check it out
um
Christian Slater will star in Willow oh
wow
okay
so are we moving on the 20th Century Fox
because Willow's not a lucasfilm
property is it
not that I'm aware of
what's going on over here at Marvel
uh
uh okay
I mean that's kind of cool I guess
why does it say why is 1 to 23 trending
final players on the Scarlet Witch solo
film
look at this
that was kind of cool that's a cool
little animation you're a cool scene
from the movie rather
um
oh Willow's lucasfilm okay I didn't know
I did not know that Willis uh that
Willow was lucasfilm because the
original Willow back in the day that was
was that a 20th Century Fox film
I'm not I don't even remember who it was
that made it I saw that film when I was
like a little kid right I want to say I
was like seven when that when I saw that
film
um thoughts on Ghost Rider news movie
Disney Plus show or just a supporting
character
um
I mean with with Ghost Rider I would
want to see
I I almost want to see a movie because I
feel like there hasn't been a proper
Ghost Rider movie since the Nicholas
Cate well there haven't been it hasn't
been a proper Ghost Rider movie since
the Nicholas Cage movie but Ronnie Reyes
in Agents of Shield was cool so I kind
of want a TV show at the same time
uh should Marvel Studios de Nerf the
Hulk for World War Hulk World breaker
Hulk and the MCU absolutely not I want
to see like a broken ass incredible Hulk
like I want to see that one just a
ridiculously op Incredible Hulk
um Willows Fox okay I'm getting answers
from both people so I don't know I mean
I'm sure I can look it up on on the
interwebs but I'm not going to so Ron
Howard directed it uh Lucas wrote the
story okay if you guys really want to
know about a movie that's that was made
by oh God who was it that made it back
in the day
um
and by I think it was Ridley Scott there
was a movie with uh Tom Tom Cruise
called legend that movie was nuts it was
Tom Cruise it was Tim Curry it was it
was an insane ass movie like it was
crazy as hell you know but it's it's got
like all these just it's got a huge cult
following uh you got a Disney Marvel
Disney Plus show of sorts of shorts idea
that you want to pitch and get out there
a Mojo show where it's parading MMA or
wrestling but he takes various
characters from different worlds errors
and dimensions of Marvel and has them
fight it out I mean sure by the way
things for 50 bucks holy sh holy crap
razor The Savage almost cussed on stream
thank you
um wow that's nuts uh
I mean it would oh Merc thanks thank you
that's cool is that is that a sticker
wait you can do stickers
I honestly didn't know that you could do
stickers uh
that's awesome
like I need to educate myself on that
kind of stuff okay so there's not not
really any updates outside of Willow and
20th Century Fox I don't know if if 20th
Century Fox is going to have a whole lot
to offer
you know I don't know what all they're
doing right I mean like we just got a
new predator on Hulu on yeah on Hulu
um maybe they'll give us a new alien I
don't know I mean that's a question like
would you guys want to see a new Alien
series that's a question that I have
uh Legend This Legend's not bad Legend
was one of those movies that you should
watch if for no other reason than just
for a personal experience
but
uh
let's see uh the Marvel panel starts
when when exactly doesn't matter because
they're doing it as like one giant panel
I think
like one huge panel
so
let's switch over to Marvel Studios for
a second
foreign Marvel Studios latest
people are saying Wanda's getting a solo
film I don't know I don't know if that's
true
uh yeah there's nothing coming out of
Marvel Studios yet
not that I'm aware of so
uh
yeah maybe that'd be nuts
um
yeah Legend was oh it was Tom Cruise's
first movie okay that makes sense
let's see
uh
uh the willow trailer's out
oh wow
oh it's the witch to turn everybody into
pigs at the end of the first movie
hey somebody plugged the willow trailer
in the the chat
Alex or Tony I don't care who it is
is that the chick that played what's her
name in Falcon and the Winter Soldier
is that Robert De Niro no way that was
Robert De Niro
it
is
God this looks cool
see I'm curious how this is going to
play out because the original Willow was
a movie
yeah the original Willow was a it was a
film okay tales of the Jedi will
premiere on October 26th okay so this I
have this I'm really really excited
about
um oh wait a minute bad batch Dave
filoni has arrived bad batch oh wow so
they they updated like that okay uh
a lot can happen over the span of like
two minutes
uh bad batch season two I'm not the
biggest fan of bad batch it's okay I'm
not overly hyped about that batch
um tales of the Jedi though okay so for
those of you guys who don't know about
at least a lot of that was kind of the
the comic side for those of you guys who
don't know about that so check this out
so the the Star Wars comics have been
produced by a few different companies so
way back in the day it was Marvel Cox
Marvel lost the Lost uh the lost the
licensing rights it went to a company
called Dark Horse Dark Horse wrote the
best stuff so like the the Old Republic
like Knights the Old Republic kind of
book line
um
the Golden Age of the Sith the force
Wars all that kind of stuff the origin
of the Jedi the origin of the Sith
that's all in the comics right now it's
all considered Legends content now
because uh basically when Marvel Studios
actually as I understand it it was
actually George Lucas who clean slated
the uh the entirety of the Disneyland
I'm sorry the Star Wars landscape
instead of Disney George Lucas was the
one who made that call but
um
yeah the idea is that they created a
whole bunch of
um of stories like one shots that
basically focus on like different
aspects of the history of the Jedi and
the Sith throughout the entirety of the
the after the entirety of the Star Wars
landscape I don't know if that's what
what they're doing here
but it was a cool concept
what
tales of the Jedi
oh they're shorts okay
this is the origin of Ahsoka
wow
oh they're Originals okay so it's not
the old stuff
foreign
wow
so is this just the origin of characters
that we never got Origins for
or just behind the scenes stuff
hold on
who is that Sith Lord
wouldn't it be crazy if they said that
well it's obviously not Revan but it'd
be cool if like Revan came back at some
point in time but like they wouldn't
they wouldn't introduce a Revan like
that as cool as that looks there's no
way that would be Revan so
yeah that wouldn't be rubbing
oh God I keep like not putting the
trailer in the center I really should my
bad guys my bad
my bad
it's it's a habit like I can't I can't
help it
well I guess it's a it's a bad habit so
no actually I think it looks kind of
cool
um
yeah the prequel to prequels
um
was that Darth Bane
oh he's in a deleted scene for Clone
Wars
okay uh give me one second guys I'm
gonna go let my dog out real quick hold
on one sec
foreign
okay
oh I know there's a younger Count Dooku
the one in the dark hair like I know
that's the younger Count Dooku
yeah at a young Dooku okay so here's our
first look
at the Young Dooku
yeah so I mean it's it's it's cool uh
what is this this is where the fun
begins
uh Star Wars memes
so
uh
[Music]
uh so they use the Mandalorian to test
oh wow they okay so the only reason why
Ahsoka showed up in
wow the only reason she showed up in
Star Wars was to see whether or not
audiences actually wanted it
I mean what do you guys think do you
guys want to see more live action Ahsoka
stuff
and the Star Wars landscape
like you guys want to see more of that
first look at Sabine and Ahsoka okay you
guys are gonna have to educate me who's
Sabine I don't know who that is because
I've never watched I've never watched
Clone Wars
foreign
I know I'm a terrible content creator
I'm terrible
okay so the Marvel panel starts in about
about 10 minutes or so
okay that's perfect
you guys want to see more Ahsoka
she's the main character now
yeah I know how dare I
watch Star Wars Rebels
she's from Rebels okay
okay should I okay should I watch Star
Wars Rebels and then Clone Wars or clone
wars and then Rebels make a pull out of
that Tony make a pull
maybe easier to answer through a poll
so
she is from Rebels okay
Dave filoni says many of the crew
working Ahsoka grew up watching the
Clone Wars that makes perfect sense and
I think that's cool I think that's cool
they grew up watching it so they want to
make content about it
so
uh I think that's a smart decision it's
like when when Marvel Studios first
launched they actually had a team of
comic book creators that were creating
content for Marvel Studios or for uh
yeah for the movies like they were
contributing to all that stuff
so
all right Clone Wars was first and then
Rebels okay
clone and then Rebels okay
people are like refresh
refresh
people are freaking out
refresh the [ __ ] Rob
stop talking and refresh
I wish I had a macro that would just
automatically refresh like every five
seconds
that would be amazing
Skeleton Crew
what Skeleton Crew I don't even know
what that is my dog is literally out
there barking
like she's just gonna have to stay out
there for a minute
uh
yeah I don't I don't know
oh they they announced ligma what's
ligma
dude I wasn't born yesterday
like ligma what
uh
uh first look at Jude Law and John Watts
Star Wars Skeleton Crew okay let me go
let this dog in Hell's Bells
this dog's got no patience whatsoever
I'm all like Boxed In by my own gear
thank you
foreign
where is Red Muffler Man where is Gordon
uh Gordon
well
Gordon is uh
kind of out of it he's uh he got locked
out of his house
so
um
let's
see
okay
the Marvel panel starts at is that 2 p.m
Eastern because that's 11 minutes from
now from where I'm at
uh what kind of dog do I have I have a
Rhodesian Ridgeback and
um
first look at Ahsoka and tales of Jedi I
don't know if it's really a first look
because we got our first look when we
saw the trailer so not really a first
look but um
I have a Rhodesian Ridgeback and Pit
Bull mix
she's adorable
she's a beautiful dog
uh
uh for the secret Wars movie what older
non-mcu actor is what I love to see
you'd love Council of Reed 1990s movie I
mean I would love the Council of reads
the council reads would be amazing
uh
okay
yeah this is all catching up
poop on you gave us five bucks I'm sorry
if I missed your Super Chat guys
I'm sorry if I missed that okay let's
update
oh man the Mandalorian season three the
Mandalorian season three
you guys excited for the Mandalorian
season three
you guys excited for that
are you guys you guys hyped
yeah Mandalorian just got announced
um this I think will automatically uh
will automatically go as like a live
video once it's done
fingers crossed
[Laughter]
so
um
let's see
there's no trailer for it yet
yeah there's no trailer yet didn't look
like
this is the way
um
let's see
Disney is streaming the d23 event on
YouTube but not anything from Marvel
Star Wars or foxy I know we saw the
streaming schedule already like they're
not they're not streaming anything
um it's your birthday on 9 11 you turn
21 and your videos have really my videos
have really helped you get through some
dark times wow thank you Jesse
thank you
I'm glad they have
wait
were you born when 9 11 happened like
the day it happened
that's rough
oh Mandalorian was infinitely better
than Boba Fett most everything was Boba
Fett was just kind of boring like
it didn't really do much for me to be
honest with you guys
so
um bro I'm the goat the greatest of all
time you know how long it took me to
realize that goat meant the greatest of
all time been watching since you were in
Middle School uh graduated high school a
year ago thank you wow that's kind of
wild to know people have been watching
for so long
hypothetically if someone were to make a
Captain carrot movie what story would
you want to see to make a movie about
the origin story where he crosses over
with Superman
oh a year after okay cool
I was like man that'd be kind of wild to
be born like the day 9 11 happened like
like when's your birthday the the same
day as the worst tragedy in the history
of the United States
like
you didn't even finish two of season two
of Boba Fett really
wow
that's kind of nuts to be honest with
you
I missed your Super Chat
oh I'm sorry
I don't know can I can I see the history
of super chats I don't know if I can see
the history of super chats
Denzel Washington is uh Kang's father
King the conqueror's dad
I am all out of coffee God I want to
make some more coffee
uh I wish I had like an assistant
they could like get me coffee be like
assistant get me more coffee you know or
I could just I could be like Thor and
just be like this was delicious another
and then like throw it on the ground
oh man
uh
okay the castle of Mandalorian season
three is on stage okay they're gonna be
dropping the trailer soon
that's the cast of of season three I
don't know why I keep clicking the image
well I'm kind of used to clicking the
image but
watch him release the Mando trailer
online and call it a day yeah this is
the way
they're using Twitter for iPad okay so
that's the cast
I don't know if you guys can see this
pop out
so there's basically everybody that we
know Pedro Pascal and so on and so forth
um people are asking where Elizabeth
Olsen is so either she's not there or
it's difficult to see her there
so
um
you sent a 200 Super Chat that I missed
no way I missed your Super Chat
uh Tony find out what his Super Chat was
and then send me send me the question
because I don't want him I don't want to
admit like 200 for a super chat I don't
want to miss that
um your brothers is Pearl Harbor
you stay indoors on your sister's
birthday wow thank you John Wheeler uh
okay let's let's make sure we get these
updates let's make sure we get these
updates going
man you guys were right about discussing
film you were 100 right about that I
should have listened to you all earlier
I should have listened to all of you
earlier
the rock is the thing you want to see
the rock it's been Grim I guess it's
like a giant rock right that'd be kind
of hilarious
um
all famous black actors as king variants
hmm
Seth Rogen has been spotted wearing a
theme a thing mask screaming I'm the
thing
oh man
that would be hilarious
I've been watching since the Franklin
Richards explained video in 2014 wow you
were 11.
you're going into University now and
have tuned into every video since 2014
wow
trombling thank you you know what
trouble and send me an email I'm gonna
send you a rob4 ring that's crazy that's
ridiculous like I I appreciate that
yeah thank you so much uh Ben Carlson
because of you I have a comic collection
and the DC and Marvel comic apps you
work at a warehouse and put my videos on
all day through your earbuds thank you
yeah I appreciate that guys big also
make sure you guys are subscribe to geek
culture explain you know make sure you
guys are sub to geek culture explain
so
the Mandalorian the book of Boba Fett or
the Mandalorian season two and a half
definitely the uh the book of Boba Fett
slash Mandalorian season two and a half
I mean it's basically the same thing
there is no real difference there right
they're like the exact same thing so I
don't really see a difference between
the two
to be honest with you guys uh let me
close the app store here
uh
yeah let me close the app store uh
we're also gonna quit Google Drive
that will turn off Bluetooth
yeah
I just got to make sure we uh
we're not overusing
stuff that we don't need to all right
let's kind of keep this going
um
it's almost Marvel time
what is the oh yeah that was already
answered hey Rob love the channel can we
see a comic book collection or like a
room tour that's the thing I've got
comic books that you can that you can
see but
um
I mean
while we're waiting for the Mandalorian
trailer to drop do you guys want to see
like a bunch of the comics that I have
I can show you guys some of them if you
want to see them I don't know how many
people actually want to see those
but I've literally got a stack of them
upstairs it's not all of them but it's
like the it's like the the cooler ones
like
um X Factor number one uh uh
there is
um
stay on discussing films
uh I hate to say it but you're tired of
seeing black The Rock and everything
like Black Adam the trailer plays so
much you feel like you have seen a
majority of the movie
no honestly there's nothing wrong I mean
that's a legitimate feeling
that's a legitimate feeling to feel that
way
right it's so it's it's perfectly okay
to just kind of be like you know what
I'm tired of seeing the Rock and
everything like there's nothing wrong
with feeling that so don't don't feel
bad about it at all
um
I mean I won't show you every comic
right like I mean there's there's stuff
like Amazing Fantasy 15 different things
like that but like the the ones that I
could go and get right now are just the
ones that are sitting sitting upstairs
like it would take me like two seconds
to go and grab those 10 seconds or so
but um
let's see
uh Taylor Russell
wins the best young actor award at the
Venice Film Festival well I don't care
about that man nobody cares about that
discussing film no one cares about the
Venice Film Festival we're here for d23
I would not have put that tweet up
like they're like it's kind of funny
like they're literally plugging our
stuff they're like make sure you guys
read our review I mean I totally get why
they're doing it right like you got to
plug your own content for example you
all should like this live stream you
should drop a like on this live stream
100 you totally should just
drop a like but um
you're like you you absolutely should do
that
uh
the hierarchy of being mid is about to
change
I love that I absolutely love that
okay Giancarlo Esposito on moth Gideon
in the Mandalorian season three you
haven't seen Moth be vulnerable before
only you can supply yourself with the
patience to find out what comes next
I don't want to see moth be vulnerable I
don't want to see him off Gideon just
talk about his feelings I think men
being able to open up with their
feelings is a very important thing I
want to see moth Gideon wreck some stuff
right that's what I want to see right
like I want to see that like I want to
see my Gideon just just crap on somebody
like
yeah
uh two super chats I sent you hope I
hope you see it I haven't watched your
stuff for a while do you still do stuff
with comic story you sent me a Super
Chat to tell me you don't watch my
content anymore
[Laughter]
why
um
I mean it's it's cool you know I don't
have any problem with that I mean that's
that's okay
um but yeah I actually just had lunch
with or had breakfast with Benny this
morning we went to a place here in town
um you know you're an OG fan when Rob's
old theme song Still slaps I mean that
song never stopped slapping so love both
channels started watching about uh five
years ago started reading comments
because of the comments explained
Channel and have your own very own
Marvel collection now that's awesome
that's awesome like I appreciate that
yeah thank you it's it's always cool to
know that like it's always cool to know
that you guys are are huge fans
um of of Marvel content or of
comfortable content in general you know
that I can kind of get you to that place
so
a trailer for The Mandalorian season 3
is being shown at d23 okay so they might
be dropping the trailer for The
Mandalorian season three soon
they might be dropping that trailer soon
okay that means we we gotta stay on it
we gotta stay on it right so uh
yeah like we we gotta we gotta stay on
it
I like how people are just like refresh
the Tweet we can't refresh the Tweet
feed
refresh people are just screaming at me
oh man
oh man
they just announced the rock as Ghost
Rider yeah haha very funny
okay so here's a question for real and
for truth if you guys could see the rock
as a character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe if the rocker going to play a
superhero in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe who would that character be who
would you want to see the rock play in
the MCU
it might just be for the room because
that's that's what they might do because
they didn't release any of the Ant-Man
and Quantum uh Ant-Man and wasps
quantumania stuff they showed it to San
Diego but they didn't release it
publicly the only way to see it was to
find like a leak video for it so
um where can I find oh uh tremolin send
me an email Rob comics explained.com
um
demon in the midst I try to watch your
stuff but I just don't have time no it's
okay it's okay I totally get it
um Katie Sackhoff says I'm so excited
for you guys to see this season of the
Mandalorian because I've I've seen it
and it's crazy honestly man I wish
they'd done more with Katie Sackhoff and
the Mandalorian man because I loved her
in that show like I feel like she's one
of those characters who just never gets
enough credit honestly I always felt
like Katie Sackhoff would have made a
great Carol Danvers in the MCU so oh the
Mandalorian season three
foreign
to be honest with you guys
no more
I loved that scene when they kicked him
out
are they gonna cover the Mandalorian
Wars
bro
God
man
[Music]
we don't even get a date it's just 2023
damn it
I mean it's February but like I want a
date I want like an actual date in 2023
okay
okay
people are just like screaming at me
refresh the damn face
the rock is mojo
wow
yeah that teaser looks great
no the Mandalorian is one of the best
right it is not a snooze Fest at all
[Music]
yeah there's not really anything
updating I mean honestly man I feel like
they need to focus on the Mandalorian
Wars okay so here's the thing there are
there's novels about the Mandalorian
Wars but there aren't really any
comments because I wish there was I wish
there was a comic series just about the
Mandalorian Wars because I would cover
that because the Mandalorian war is the
closest you get to that is the nicely
Old Republic comic books and the video
game but the nicely older probably
Comics even even though even with a
video game though the okay so in the old
the original coach war game with like
Revan and Malik and those guys the uh
the Mandalorian wars were over
right like
the Mandalorian words I'll grab you all
secret chats here in a second but the
Mandalorian wars were done right so like
in the comic book
um you actually end up getting the
Mandalorian Wars as a uh as like a
background to what's going on until you
get to like this five issue miniseries
of the Mandalorian Wars for that
literally focuses on the mandolin Wars
itself right but I don't I want to see
like a series that focuses on the
entirety of that
so okay
um let's see you're tired of seeing
Black Adam okay so uh hi Rob so if I
were a director in just in another in
another life my plan to revive the DCU
um introduce Sarah pazzini in a Solo
Film Iron Man style then make a the
darkness movie with Jackie estacado as a
solo I don't know who any of those guys
are so yeah I don't know oh then
introduce a Constantine Constantine in
Italian film then make a solo Tomb
Raider film then make a Batman film
tying in which blade is a cameo then
move forward from there what do you
think I think your entire thing is like
all over the place
so Indiana Jones 5 announced no way
that's true
first look at the Mandalorian season
three yeah we already watched the
trailer for Mandalorian yeah we already
watched that that trail it doesn't
really feel like a teaser it feels like
a full-on trailer
but yeah we already watched that so
um
the first thing you thought of the Rock
in the in the dce or the MCU is the
Marquee of death
the Rockets Clyde wincham just wouldn't
be believable
right the Rockets Clyde windshield it
just it's not really believable in that
way I mean it's cool don't get me wrong
but it's not really believable you know
like I wouldn't really you know I I
couldn't really see it that way
yeah uh first look at Indiana Jones
being shown exclusively oh exclusively
to d23 so no one outside of d23 gets to
see it so this is going to be like the
Ant-Man and wasp quantumania footage of
San Diego which was cool to see but
nobody else got to see it outside of
anybody who was in San Diego but this
does look awesome
yeah look at this
release the trailer frauds look at that
somebody like somebody's screaming at
him right off the bat
what do you guys think about that what
do you guys think about that look of
Indiana Jones I mean it's just kind of
him but I feel like Harrison Ford man
like he's too old to be playing Indiana
Jones you know what I mean like
um
the rock is knife Thrasher Gladiator
will be a cool choice
uh the rock is Mr Sinister no probably
not
the rock is apocalypse or null
see I'm very very picky about who would
play characters in the MCU I love the
rock he's really interesting but I
couldn't see him as I could see him as
like Crusher creel the absorbing man but
the problem is the rock is not going to
play a side character he's not going to
play a second tier character
um hey Rob I don't know if you streamed
on here before but uh you're so glad to
see that I'm streaming right now live
geek culture is awesome been watching
you since I was a kid and you covered
Civil War initially said oh I appreciate
that yeah thank you for that
I appreciate that
so uh
the rock is Red Hulk
oh man
uh
first look at bocaton it's not really a
first look we saw that in the trailer
mingled says both Steven Spielberg and
George Lucas have been involved with
Indiana Jones five so what's the
throwback to like the old Indiana Jones
like the Temple of Doom Raiders of the
Lost Ark the Last Crusade
yeah definitely a throwback to those
which Indiana Jones here's my question
which Indiana Jones movie was your
favorite
right which Indiana Jones movie was your
absolute favorite that's what I want to
know
yeah which one which one was your
favorite
uh
okay
sorry about that guys I had to do
something real quick
uh
okay here are some Ford cries on stage
after the first look at Indiana Jones 5
is revealed on stage damn so so I wonder
I wonder if he's gonna die in this one
if Indiana Jones is gonna die
in this
yeah I wonder if that's gonna happen uh
the rocket King thanks for all you do
Rob both of your both your both for your
comic knowledge and your positivity
presently you're building up a digital
silver Age collection yeah Silver age
comics where those those Comics were
crazy as hell
um
the d23 schedule says Marvel isn't
showing until 2 p.m Pacific
uh what
hey Rob been watching since about 2015
love the work
am I worried am I at all worried they
don't get uh Dr Doom right also The Rock
you want the rock as manifold I could
see that but I'm a little on the fence
about that but manifold was never really
important to me so it wouldn't really
matter to me if they if they screwed it
up and got it wrong
I'd be I mean I wouldn't mind
uh
yeah not really any more updates yet
uh
uh
okay
yeah Creative Cloud is like a resource
hog I can hate that
yeah like Creative Cloud just freaking
kills
battery life
okay
Harrison Ford says Indiana Jones 5 is is
his final time that's it I'm not falling
down for you again okay so I think
they're gonna kill Harrison Ford at the
end of Indiana like in Indiana Jones
five yeah no so they were saying the
trailer for Indiana Jones 5 is
exclusively exclusive to San Diego I'm
sorry to uh d23
that nobody is getting anything from
from that
okay
when does the Marvel panel start
because this was lucasfilm
so
oh man next up is Marvel Studios if you
aren't already follow discussing film
and turn on notifications we are live
tweeting every piece of news yes okay
Marvel Studios
okay
everybody relax stay calm stay calm it's
like that Meme from Office okay
okay everybody stay calm everybody calm
down calm down there's Marvel Studio
Marvel Studios okay okay
I've been watching you since you were
19. now you're 30.
uh wait that doesn't make any sense
did you have like a Time skip because I
haven't been I haven't been creating
content that long that's like 11 years
so
okay
yes tomorrow
[Music]
stay calm
come on
disgusting film man give me that [ __ ]
give me that stuff man
okay
I'm so excited for this
uh foggy says he is a little shocked
after watching the Indiana Jones 5
footage as he begins as Marvel
d23 Expo presentation okay that's cool I
guess whatever
like give me the Marvel Studio stuff
uh
come on man
God I'm like I'm like super hardcore
jonesing
like I am super hardcore jonesing right
now
okay live performance of Rogers musical
at d23 they're doing a live performance
of the musical man get to the movie
announcements man man
yeah exactly it's time it's time
Pro tip if you use the r to do a quick
refresh no so I'm using the actual
Twitter app for Mac so I have to like
drag down like the control R doesn't
work so I'm not using a browser
I've been following you since early days
do you think we finally get a proper uh
living appearance of the Living Tribunal
in Guardians of the Galaxy 3 given his
relationship with Adam Warlock I mean
Adam warlock's relationship was
um was was closer yeah make sure you
guys share the lines live stream with
people like make sure you guys share so
people know what's going on
um Adam warlock's
um relationship with with his
relationship was closer more to
the um I don't want to see no
Mandalorian updates man I want to see
Marvel Studios
stop showing me updates for the
Mandalorian man
I don't want to see that I guess maybe
they're just kind of killing time while
they do the musical which is kind of
cool I guess I mean I would go see the
musical for for
like Roger I mean it'd be cool you know
but like
no I have I have no desire to
to see that right now
like no desire at all
okay
okay come on update update
update bro
there's nothing coming out man
I want to see them announced like the
X-Men man I want to see him announce the
X-Men that's what I want
I want to see them announce like the the
X-Men
in the MCU man have I ever covered what
if uh the older what-if Comics No but I
might give it a shot
Barack refresh the damn fact
Uh Kevin feige is about to begin the
Marvel reveals for d23 Expo
yeah you said that before
discussing film man
bro like come on guys get it together
come on man update okay so here's a
question while we're waiting for this to
update while we're waiting for this to
update what do you want to see the most
from uh from D from d23 from Marvel
what's what's the one thing you gotta
see from Marvel's d23 also as always
guys make sure you make sure you drop a
like on the stream make sure you guys
just drop a like on the stream just give
us a like button there just just give us
a like on this stream
uh
but yeah what's the what's the thing
that you guys want to see from Marvel
Studios oh the light performance no I
don't care about the live I mean well
actually I kind of care a little bit all
right hold on let's take a look at this
yeah this is this is kind of cool
like a quick little live thing did they
do that as San Diego Tony I can't
remember off top of my head they did a
live performance of no no they did it at
the end of a series that's what that was
they did it at the end of a series which
was kind of cool I guess so
and that was kind of cool you want to
see Daredevil you want to see Wanda
okay Tony make a poll asking how many uh
how many of them want to see the X-Men
revealed
at d23
how many of you guys want to see the
X-Men
how many of you guys want to how many of
you guys want to see X-Men d23
I don't want to make a poll on that
um
hold on where is there we go
bro
with the updates though man
I guess this musical's taking a little
while I will say this you know what was
cool as hell being at San Diego and
being able to actually see that whole
live performance for black panther that
was amazing holy hell it was myself Tony
Quran and Gordon
yeah who are all there dude we got to
see it live it was it was such an
amazing experience
it was a ridiculously awesome experience
yeah
uh do you understand why Marvel is doing
an Agatha TV series there's so many more
characters they should explore I just
don't get why she's getting a show
because people like Agatha Harkness and
they want to learn more about her
character one of the reasons do you need
besides that
that's reason enough for me
to be honest with you guys all right
let's let's refresh let's refresh we're
refreshing first look at yaddle and
tales of the Jedi I don't give a damn
about that man I'm here for the Marvel
Studios panel I'm not here
for yaddle
from Tales of the Jedi like I have no
interest in that
I am not here for that
at all
although it is kind of cool
I mean it's kind of interesting I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna scoff at that but
it's kind of cool but
not really here for that
all right let's refresh this feed man
first up is Black Panther wakanda
forever okay dude it was so cool to see
that trailer man there wasn't a dry eye
in that whole entire place when that
trailer dropped there was not a dry eye
anywhere like it was it was wild to see
it was wild
yeah it was crazy
okay how many of you guys were excited
for black panther wakanda forever
how many of you guys are excited for
that
all right let's refresh this thing
because I wanna I wanna know I want to
know how many of you guys are how many
of you guys are just hyped
for that
yeah I know they're doing wakanda
forever but
No Woman No Cry yeah I've been a fan
since 1979 you're 22 years
now things for several hours of content
I appreciate it uh Alex I'm not
I haven't been creating content since
1979 but thank you
so
Ryan coogler says he's still in the
editing process and Cutting Room for
black panther wakanda forever wow so
he's still putting the video together
damn or the movie rather
I keep talking like he's a content
creator
new footage from Black Panther what kind
of forever is being shown exclusively at
d23 damn it
Noah
oh
tweet out what's in the footage at the
very least
all right so the new footage for black
panther wakana forever is not being
released publicly it's only being shown
at d23 dude
come on Marvel
come on
you're pumped for it
exclusive footage yeah I know I mean
it's it's you're not like I never get
upset about that like when I'm there and
I get to see the exclusive footage but
when I'm not there and I don't get to
see it that's when it becomes a problem
like that's when it becomes an issue
um
okay
let's refresh
like at least tell us what's in the
footage
that's what I want to know because
that's what I was doing like when we
were that's what that's what Tony was
doing when we were in San Diego we were
tweeting out which make sure you guys
follow our Twitter account
um but we were tweeting I told you if
you'll link to that by the way but we
were tweeting out literally what was
happening in the trailer at that point
like we were just tweeting out what was
what was being seen there
been a fan since 2035 you're 22 years
old now
yeah thanks for the content yeah
been a fan since 1902.
thanks for the content Rob
uh okay while we're waiting for an
update
while we're waiting for an update do you
think we're gonna see Fantastic Four
stuff at d23
do you think they're holding Fantastic
Four for d23
what do you guys think
what do you guys think
so sad the queen won't be alive to see
Secret Wars I mean yeah it's tragically
going done uh Jamie Lannister is Doom
I love how you guys just call him Jamie
Lannister instead of his actual name
because you guys can't remember his name
so it's just
Jamie Lannister
hmm damn it I wish we would get to see
that extra footage man
foreign
God it's been like two minutes man what
else is going on
just update man God
you think this is the cash reveal for
the Fantastic Four
that's fair the cash reveal for
Fantastic Four would be pretty legit
the official trailer for Tales of the
Jedi yeah that's kind of cool I guess
like what I we're at the Marvel Studios
right now man I don't care about Star
Wars I care about Marvel stuff I care
about Marvel content
that's what I want to see
I want to see Marvel stuff bro I haven't
even had lunch yet it's like 12 30. I
haven't even had lunch
I haven't I actually well I had
breakfast I had biscuits and gravy with
eggs and bacon
and I've still got like an entire desk
thing to work on upstairs
that's gonna be cool
I'm like building a whole shelling unit
into a closet it's gonna be so awesome
when it's done
I am so looking forward to it
nothing updated yet okay
Henry Cavill is Dr Doom yes or no no I'd
rather see Henry Cavill as um as
Hyperion
because the the rumors are saying that
Henry Cavill is going to be in Loki
season two
um who cooks at my house I do but the
rumor is saying that Henry Cavill is
going to be playing Loki I'm sorry Henry
Cavill Henry cavill's playing Loki uh
Henry Cavill is in Loki season two
playing Hyperion
so
uh you want Marvel to just really
release a trailer and post her for
Fantastic Four without putting out the
cast
huh
all right black panther wakanda forever
focuses on the rest of the world trying
to capitalize on getting wakanda's
resources when they're at their weakest
that is Doom War okay so so here's the
rumor here's the rumor here's here
here's the rumor the rumor is that
doctor I'm sorry that uh the Doctor Doom
well okay so the rumor is that he's
supposedly gonna be in a post-credancy I
don't know if that's true or not that's
the leak whatever
but this is Doom War except it's the
rest of the world because I imagine that
what there is is in the movie they'll
just simply say that like t'challa had
basically died by whatever man or
whatever means t'challa's died to
reflect the fact that Chadwick Boseman
that our King has our King has passed
away I don't know I don't know what the
cool the cruel I don't know what kind of
gesture I should be making but uh this
like I don't know what gesture to make
that's like respectful to chat with
Bozeman but also just kind of like he's
our guy
um but but like I imagine them the movie
will reflect that so what it's going to
do is it's gonna it literally is gonna
open up and everybody trying to take
control or to utilize wakanda in some
capacity and I think Dr Doom will be the
one that's successful
he'll be the one that successfully pull
it off but that's this is literally Doom
war with more people except just Doctor
Doom so
yeah
but been watching uh since my OG Civil
War videos in 2014. wow that's a long
time
now you're a grown adult working in Tech
keep it up with the old the great
content also love the old school intro
from back then yeah I appreciate it man
if I didn't run into so many copyright
problems I never would have
put up with it
like I would have just kept it but it
just it created so many copyright issues
well I just created so many problems
okay so I'm not seeing anything here
no updates yet
hmm
come on guys come on guys
don't leave me hanging
don't leave me hanging
give me some good stuff
okay Expo footage uh for black panther
what kind of forever including a shot a
lot of name or action including him
fighting umbaku oh bro the name of the
Submariner fighting a Baku
bro
I am so down for that I am so down for
that
ah
they revealed Robert Downey Jr as Iron
Man
hmm
let's see what d23 has got going on
oh wow okay so they have pictures and
stuff discussing film doesn't have any
pictures or anything
I do 23 shows okay so the Black Panther
wakanda forever footage of d23 shows
Riri flying namor's Incredible strength
and the Dora Malachi fighting soldiers
trying to steal vibranium bro God this
movie's gonna be so good
this movie is going to be so good
God
the kid named finger
the Temple of geek God I wish I was one
of the people who were there
okay you know what we're going to jump
out of nerds we're going to jump onto
these guys
had like a video yeah okay these guys
are what's up man these guys are what's
up they've got like video and stuff
there's like the
the Rogers thing okay
iron heart and a tumor in action but the
heart of it is Queen raimonda speaking
up about how the rest of the world can't
handle vibranium okay
see that's that's detailed
I dig that
okay that's detailed
um so Marvel's Marvel's panel is about
an hour long unless it happens to be
longer but
these guys better be updating all right
you know what we'll just we'll just go
with like the general thing because
everybody's updating
at different points in time
there's that guy right there
otherwise don't be shy Marvel release
the Black Panther clip
a teaser trailer okay it looks like
they're still talking
Iron Heart
are they going to release footage for
ironheart
is getting the crowd emotional damn
okay what is this
okay that's just some money walking on
stage
um wow okay so that's the poster for
ironheart
it looks like
which will lead into a new Disney plus
series okay
first look at ironheart that looks
awesome
holy cow okay this is this is all like
way too much okay let's just go back to
discussing a film because there's just
there's so much stuff going on there
there is so much going on there
exclusively for San Diego so it's
exclusive there like there's no there's
there's nothing
damn it
God
this is nuts okay we got some we got
some super chats we need to follow
um I got you hooked on Comics collected
a bunch of Batman X-Men Fantastic Four
now you're mildly addicted yeah I'm glad
man welcome to the rabbit hole right
enjoy your Falls
crazy
um
thanks for making me more knowledgeable
on comics
you grew up on oh thanks yeah I mean
it's no problem it's just it's what I
love uh you grew up in one or you've
been you've been watching since 2bc
uh will Wanda be the molecule man of
Secret Wars MCU I think so I think so
there's a teaser exclusive to San Diego
okay or to d23
damn it okay Marvel's training let's see
what Marvel says let's see what level
says over here
okay there's nothing that's all they're
way back you're way behind
okay should we stick with discussing
film or or do you guys want me to look
at all the other like just the whole of
the d23 hashtag what do you guys want
what do you guys want
oh Anthony Ramos plays the hood and iron
heart okay I'm totally down for that
right it's Parker Robbins okay so that
knocks out the fan theories that were
going on that uh Donnie Blaze is playing
the hood in the MCU
so yeah he's playing Parker Robbins do
Parker Robbins man he's the Parker
Robbins is the guy that you just you you
love to root on you have to root him on
right you want to see him succeed but
like he never really does but he always
ends up in like just these huge schemes
like there's one where he got The
Infinity Gauntlet he assembled the whole
Infinity Gauntlet for himself like it
was it was crazy
so
all of d23
all of d23
wow all like the whole d23 hashtag
the biggest thing wow black panther
wakanda forever is the biggest thing
they've ever done
okay
you guys are asking for d23 so let's
let's do
d23
what's the latest
what's the scoop
the first teacher of Iron Heart teaser
gives us he gives the best look of Ruby
suit and Parker's Hood God it's gonna be
so cool
to drop a freestyle explain the heart of
the plot of ironheart
revealed to be executive producing the
upcoming ironheart series trailer shown
exclusive yeah yeah
hold on what
oh that looks like that that is not
actually from the I was like man that's
CGI could use a little bit of work
you know what I mean
like man they're really
Fair on that CGI
oh man
you need a Scarlet Witch movie yeah the
chat is lit right this chat is
absolutely lit
uh
okay Iron Heart
Anthony Ramos is the hood yeah we know
that
a new and or trailer yeah
what
Ant-Man and wash Quantum video
watch Quantum media y'all know what that
means man
yes okay Kane the Conqueror all right
what are they saying
God there's just so much here
like people are just like updating late
so it's just like you end up you end up
having to scroll through like a bunch of
stuff you don't care about
okay you know what let's let's just go
back to discussing film that's that's
just easier
that's just easier
okay
going with one source it's just
infinitely easier than people who are
like updating but they're they're doing
it like late you know what I mean so
it's just infinitely easier that way
we're gonna get nothing
no you gotta you gotta think positive
man you got to think positive you got to
think positive
right you got to keep that positivity
going
come on update
okay so so do you guys think they're
gonna drop a full trailer for Ant-Man
and wash quantumania while we're waiting
do you guys think they're gonna drop a
full trailer
Murphy's Multiverse Twitter trust me
okay let's check out Murphy's Multiverse
Twitter
Murphy's Multiverse at d23
okay
jokes about Paul Rudd being the sexiest
man alive
uh
I wish they would get rid of that pin
tweet man so you don't have to scroll
past it every time you want to see
what's going on
#d23
yeah they don't have any update yet
okay
okay we're just gonna stick with we're
gonna stick with these guys they've
treated us well so far
they've treated us well so far so
we're not going to bail on them we're
going to be there when they need us
[Laughter]
okay
uh when I cover Ghost Rider comics yes
uh
you haven't gotten the full you haven't
gotten a full black panther trailer yet
yeah well I mean we did we got a pretty
solid trailer
from Black Panther
okay there's like no update yet
what are they even waiting on it's been
like three or four minutes
okay at manowas quantumania links
directly with Avengers the King Dynasty
okay so one probably segues into the
other so I wouldn't be surprised this
movie basically ends with the fact that
they're like okay we have to like
assemble a team to stop king or Loki
meets up with Ant-Man
and just goes directly from there
uh
hmm
cover marble Max
the quantumania trailer is exclusive
damn
no way
these guys need to get on it man like
I'm getting really impatient with how
long they're taking to update
like just update in real time
because I'm getting really really tired
of waiting right like
we only update the big news we don't
update like we don't we don't uh
I wish there was a Twitter account
that's like just just rapid updates on
like here's what's happening like
like we'll post a picture if we get a
chance but like here's here's like
what's actually happening in real time
right like
exclusive trailer for Ant-Man and wasp
okay so yeah nobody gets to see it
besides them
so that's probably why they're not a lot
live streaming it because they had
exclusive trailers that they were going
to show so nobody else gets to see it
that sucks
okay so Ant-Man and Washington they're
on stage to just talk about the movie
okay
ant-manuel's quantumanian trailer is
being shown
directly to Avengers the King Dynasty
God it's gonna be so good
I am so excited about that wow okay so
okay it's time to go back to discussing
Phil
oh did you guys see it
since
oh man
[Laughter]
oh man
you guys saw that you saw nothing
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man
[Laughter]
I can't believe that showed up
people like bra
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
dude the stream is going nuts
oh man
oh smash
oh she was getting old
oh my God
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man that was hilarious
oh man that was hysterical
oh man
did you see anything
oh man
[Laughter]
oh my God
I don't know why that's so funny to me
but that's hilarious
oh
we got our epic stream moment
oh my goodness
oh
oh it was hilarious man it was just the
the situation it was the context
it was funny as hell
you're like nope I didn't see anything
oh man
[Laughter]
going nuts
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
all right let's update this let's update
this okay so Randall Park returns is
Jimmy woo and Ant-Man and was quantity I
mean we kind of knew that already didn't
we like did we already know that that
was already confirmed in some capacity
right Paul Rudd says this unlike
anything we've seen before all right so
it's just kind of them out there talking
so that's cool
oh my God
uh step Hulk what are you doing
that was so hilarious
dude we hit the Panic Button as soon as
we saw that
that was the preview for the next
episode
oh man
oh my goodness
oh man
okay
uh where we'll find out is officially
announced badass all right new footage
of Ant-Man was quantumia shown in d23
Scotland having to do a heist in the
quantum realm for king or else he won't
get Cassie back wow so King makes him do
a high I don't know how I feel about
that but we'll see we'll see yeah we'll
see how it goes all right werewolf by
night I'm I'm really excited for Jack
Russell I'm really excited for werewolf
by night and yes that's the name of
where we'll probably have not it quite
literally is Jack Russell that's his
name he was not it was not a creative
name at all
he was named after a dog
okay so I'm excited for werewolf by
night I'm I'm excited for that like I'm
looking forward to that
that's gonna be awesome
but uh
oh man
oh
okay yeah so where will finites
announced that's cool
um I wonder what I was gonna I wonder
how that's gonna be
involved
like who all is going to be a part of
that project
like I wonder if they're gonna have Moon
Knight in there because technically Moon
Knight originally appeared in a werewolf
By Night comic
so
uh Michael Gia Chino is officially
revealed as the director for werewolf by
night he has previously worked in the
MCU as a composer for scores including
no way home
um wait so they have a they have a
musician directing the film
that's interesting
not that uncommon
it's not that crazy but okay I mean I
could definitely get behind that but
um
the best story you covered that you've
that you watched first was Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four I love
tickman's Fantastic Four
so
uh Comics explain that yeah
that came out of that that just came out
of nowhere
um here's to make up for that
demonetization that just occurred yeah I
don't think it was on screen long enough
you expect a 30 minute episode on that
one panel we just saw you know what you
know what we should do guys so for
everybody watching this stream right now
you know what we should do we should
like as soon as the stream goes live
like we just like like we might just
like get rid of the the video on demand
and it'll just be our secret nobody else
will know about it besides uh so it'll
just be like our inside joke so like if
you weren't there for the stream you
don't know what happened I don't know I
think it'd be funny
so we probably won't do that but it'd be
hilarious
so
hopefully
oh man
uh
um
it was on screen long enough
oh man
uh
okay
um
Gail Garcia Bernal and Laura Donnelly
are the leads of werewolf by nine okay
that's cool honestly I'm not overly
excited about werewolf finite
um I'm not super hyped for that I mean
it'll be interesting to see but nothing
about werewolf why not gets me super
excited but it also depends on how they
handle it
um the Hulk incident yeah that's what we
can call it just the Hulk incident
out of context panels explained
you were traumatized oh man
okay
but yeah I'm not overly excited on
werewolf one I mean it's interesting
I'll watch it
um but there was there was never really
I mean even before the MCU there was
never really anything about werewolf by
night that got me super excited about
the character right there was yeah there
was never anything that got me like
super hyped
about his character it was just it was
kind of cool you know it was just sort
of a cool thing so
yeah are you excited about werewolf by
nine that's the question that's the
question
a new trailer all right let's update
this
oh here we go
Marvel's special presentation
foreign
okay I'm gonna love this it's like a
comedic horror
it literally feels like an old school
horror film
foreign
this is wild
yeah this feels like a throwback to like
the old 70s horror horror like movies
and stuff like that like this is gonna
be awesome
yeah this is gonna be super cool
it's gonna be really unique
yeah I'm looking forward to that okay
I'm totally down for that
uh yeah people are changing their vote
now
hmm
what's that sound
it's like a weird sound
huh
I don't even know what that is uh okay
let's update
oh the first poster for werewolf by
night that's gonna be awesome
yeah the werewolf y9 is a black and
white retro horror mystery you know what
I'm totally down for that because that's
probably one of the only things that's
going to make werewolf By Night
interesting is to do it as kind of a
retro throwback
yeah anything beyond that and it's just
not gonna it's not gonna resonate with
people but I think I think pitching it
and doing it in a unique way like that
is going to be cool so
Secret Wars is about the green circle
incident
[Laughter]
oh man
okay let's update
oh secret invasion
okay secret Invasion and armor Wars I'm
so glad we're hearing something about
armor Wars okay for those of you guys
who don't know anything about that armor
Wars was a story back in the day where
basically I think Justin Hammer had paid
a guy to steal the tech of Tony Stark or
at least the ability to make Stark Tech
to make our Iron Man suits and then they
were sold by Justin Hammer I think to
virtually all these different people
um different villains so what you had
were a whole bunch of villains who were
running around with Tony Stark's armor
so if I'm a betting man because of the
way that the events of
um
the events of infinity war and in-game
ended I wouldn't be surprised if armor
Wars involves sheer uh um shuri I'm
sorry not sure um Ruby Williams in some
capacity but that people basically stole
Stark Tech and they're building Iron Man
suits as a result of that it might even
have callbacks to Iron Man 2.
oh a trailer for Secret Wars
wait didn't we see this in San Diego
so she's probably the queen
I bet Don Cheadle is a girl
holy cow
yeah so that's not new that's that's
nothing new I don't know if it's new to
you guys I don't remember if they
released it publicly but we saw it at
San Diego I'm pretty sure
so yeah so that's that's the thing
that's there that's a thing that exists
but
yeah so if so okay so for those of you
guys who don't know
um YouTube has so on Twitch you can do
that on YouTube you can't YouTube all
has like it's always running content ID
so the instant that that audio plays
it'll pull it and it'll it'll shut the
stream down
so
I'm doing good William thank you
uh She-Hulk
[Laughter]
oh man
okay it's new to you guys okay cool
okay they didn't release it publicly
okay yeah so then we saw it at San Diego
it was cool it was really really
exciting to see but yeah I didn't know
they hadn't released it in San Diego or
hadn't released it publicly because the
thing is like once once it releases in
San Diego like I've seen it and so it
just kind of gives purged out of my
brain of like whether or not it's public
or whether or not it's not it's just
like I've seen it so my brain doesn't
discern the difference
yeah first look at Olivia Coleman in
secret Invasion I'm going to bet she's
uh she's not it's not sluggert who's the
queen of the um excuse one slickert's
one of the goddesses Cleveland and
Slugger are the gods and goddesses uh or
the god and goddess of the scroll race
um
can't remember the name of the queen
during Secret Wars or secret Invasion I
never can I always forget the name of
the Queen
so posters behind me yeah these are Alex
Ross posters
um what am I eating for lunch I have no
idea
uh secret Invasion should be in the
movies that's a big Marvel event it is a
big Marvel event yeah it's a huge Marvel
event
so
yeah massive event
uh for yeah that's who it is thank you
thank you so much
I can I can never ever remember the
Queen's name yes thank you
uh Don Cheadle says armor Wars begins
filming next year and is set right after
secret Invasion okay
so that's gonna be interesting I wonder
if I wonder how and if they tie together
okay so if it's set to begin filming
next year they don't even have they
won't even have a trailer for it
um yeah it's just like it's a thing
we're working on so honestly I think the
reason why Don Cheadle is out talking
about armor Wars at the moment is so
that people don't forget about it
because that was a big question people
had is like what's going on with armor
Wars like is there anything about armor
Wars and like nobody was talking about
it people had just kind of forgotten
about it so
yeah
um
let's see did I see man thing no I
didn't see man thing in the trailer for
I mean I can go back and watch the
werewolf By Night trailer so
oh okay Hugh Quan has been cast as Loki
in season two also um Tony Tony I'm
gonna send you a message real quick
uh
oh yeah okay so yeah
um
okay so Loki season two see okay so
here's the thing is I understand it the
rumors were saying that Henry Cavill is
gonna play Hyperion in Loki season two
and I don't even know if that's true
enough I doubt it's true but I don't
know if that's true and I kind of want
it to be
so okay so so Tony make a poll on that
do you guys think that Henry Cavill will
be in Loki season two
do you think you'll play Hyperion in
Loki season 2.
Emilia Clarke and secret Invasion yeah
he looks okay
you know she looks okay
I mean do they literally come out there
like okay so like so they're announcing
all this stuff after Don Cheadle says
that so did Don Cheadle present like
secret Invasion and then uh oh Loki's on
stage dude I bet dude I bet they have a
trailer for Loki season two it better
not be exclusive I'm gonna be pissed if
it is
I'm gonna be so mad if it is
I'm gonna be so pissed off but um
I don't even know I don't even know what
I was gonna ask
[Laughter]
uh oh yeah so do you think like Don
Cheadle came out presented like secret
secret invasion is like by the way armor
Wars is going to be like nothing you've
ever seen before thanks and then just
left like is that is that how that went
like is that how that conversation went
I'm kind of curious God I could go for
some Chinese food for lunch I could do
that I have 80d so bad so like I'm never
I'm like I'm like never focused and I'm
never on topic I'm always just kind of
like everywhere
so yeah like I'm always kind of all over
the place
God man it's it's really really like in
the in the middle
um but yeah if they if they have man
thing in werewolf by night that's kind
of my question because the thing about
the thing about his character in the
comics is like people who know fear
burned at the touch of the man thing so
like
like I don't know how that's gonna work
like how does that dog bark
yeah okay they haven't they haven't
updated anything yet I guess the Loki's
talking about it
but yeah so my uh so Alex told me to
avoid the d23
um hashtag because people are posting
inappropriate stuff on there which uh we
now know so
I guess I almost accidentally
deleted
oh
[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
oh my goodness oh my goodness
uh why am I not a d23 honestly because
it's easier to not be a d23 because we
can turn around and just post content so
all the trailers exclusive
oh no
this is in the panel from Indiana Jones
okay I guess that's what he says
um
wait so the Loki season true trailer is
exclusive to uh to d23
well that's fine I mean it's gonna it's
gonna leak out but no one of the things
we realized like we we enjoyed Hall age
in San Diego it was fun it was a cool
experience
um I'm probably not going to do it again
honestly I think it's more it's more
effective and it's easier for us to do
our jobs if we can literally do what
we're doing right now one we can produce
this content for you guys so we can all
kind of watch it together as a group and
be super excited I can make sense out of
some of the stuff that we're seeing so
you guys can get some context and then
we can also literally just produce
content in real time so we can we can
throw stuff out because I mean this this
is all stuff that we cannot do at like
at d23 or Hall h it's cool as it would
be to do that like we just it's hard for
us to produce content there the only way
for us to be able to do that is to send
somebody as like a field correspondent
that would have that would actually be
present at d23 but then other people
would actually stay back home and they
would be the ones producing content for
it but
um
but yeah
so
oh yeah that is man thing and werewolf
By Night yep still that's so they're
burning right there so that's the idea
behind man thing so the way it works man
thing guards the uh guards the Florida
Everglades which honestly this might
even be a tie end of that because man
thing guards the four uh the Florida
Everglades which is a which gives you
access to
um the Multiverse if you can pass
through it uh
the new official logo for armor Wars
okay that's cool
um
but yeah so those who know fear like
literally burn at the touch of the man
thing like you'll just set on fire and
you'll burn up it's one of the craziest
things
there's absolutely Bonkers it's cool but
it's absolutely bonkers
so
um
nothing to say about Fantastic Four
come on really
no uh
no
bro really
okay maybe we'll get some X-Men stuff
let's not lose hope maybe we'll get some
X-Men stuff
right
yeah maybe we'll get some X-Men stuff
we'll see what's up
nothing to say about Fantastic Four
today oh
what else is there Deadpool potentially
uh
there's like there's no updates yet okay
Echo his rap filming oh
okay so so then then it's got to be
something big it's got to be like the
X-Men or or the egg or like Deadpool or
something like that
yeah I know they announced the director
but like
no it's got It's gotta be something big
it's got to either be Deadpool or X-Men
It's gotta be it's gotta be one of those
two right they can't show up to d23 this
year and say we've got nothing to say
about Deadpool or the X-Men like there's
no way that happens
there's no way that happens
okay Matt shackman is officially
directing the Fantastic Four but no
casting today okay that's fine
hmm
that sucks
see my thought was if the rumors were
true okay I could see why they didn't do
why they wouldn't do that because the
rumors circulating around or that Dr
Doom has a post-credits scene in uh
Black Panther too if they March the the
guy out for black for for Doctor Doom
right the actor for Dr Doom people would
immediately know that the post-credits
scene for black panther is correct
because they would they already have the
guy cast and they're like yep he's going
to be the post-critic scene Vincent
d'onofio Returns His Kingpin and Echo
with a Band-Aid a bandage over his eye
that's the most Wilson Fisk thing ever
to get shot in the face and just cover
it with a bandage right to just kind of
be like yup that happens sometimes you
know and then just like walk away like
that would be that's the most most
Kingpin thing ever the most Kingpin
thing ever
they're not talking about hearing the
cowboy yet okay that's that's okay wait
we can't lose hope don't lose hope right
ladies and gents do not lose hope
less less than that let's not lose hope
okay so here's a question Tony make a
poll out of this here's the question
would you guys want to see Henry Cavill
as Doctor Doom in the MCU
me personally
no
footage for Loki season 2 included a lot
more Kang action and they had to make an
exclusive bro no no uh
why
uh that sucks
that sucks
what I wouldn't have given to see that
you said you've lost hope
that's a no
laughs
people are just like no
at least you guys are honest
at least you guys are honest right I
can't fault you guys for that
he's like no
Henry Cavill does not have the acting
chops to play Doctor Doom really
I figured as much as you guys love Henry
Cavill you'd want to see him as Doctor
Doom
honestly I feel like if anybody were
gonna play uh play Hyperion it would be
him
he would play Hyperion Marcus Milton
Earth one three zero uh one three zero
three four the good version of Hyperion
because there's there's King Hyperion
who's a villain there's the original
Hyperion from Earth 715 who's kind of a
villain but not necessarily sort of
depending on who was writing the story
at the time
um and then there yeah then there's
Marcus Milton from Earth one three zero
three four so yeah
that would definitely be the guy
come on updates give us like Deadpool
give us X-Men something
something
it's got to be something man
oh my God
plays a TVA employee in Loki season two
Okay so
I don't know if like they remember or
something like that
that's not important news at all
thou would not tweet about that I would
not say that's important news at all
no that's not important at all
uh
you're depressed now
he would make a good Vulcan
he would make a good Vulcan
uh the clock is ticking it's a Black
Bolt movie
what would you guys have done if uh if
Henry Cavill had been cast as Black Bolt
like what would you guys have done in
that instance
it would have been hilarious so what
would you have done like Henry Cavill
have been cast as Black Bolt
because I think it would have been
hilarious it would have sucked but it
would have been hilarious at the same
time
kill or Celia Murphy is Doctor Doom or
nothing like him or nothing
no no now here's the thing we don't know
if the panel we don't know if the panel
is done yet we don't know if the panel
is done yet so we don't know if they
have any more any more tricks up their
sleeve
And discussing film is being super slow
on their updates so
they're being ridiculously slow like
obnoxiously slow
like I would just be tweeting non-stop
because that's what we were doing we
were just tweeting non-stop we were like
this this this this this like it was
just non-stop updates
hmm
first look at Don Cheadle and secret
Invasion all right so maybe they're
gearing up for the next next
presentation
thank you
yeah maybe there's gearing up for the
next presentation
I don't know we'll find out we'll find
out
it would have just been the perfect Fu
to DC and Warner Brothers have you
played Hyperion it really would right
they're like we can make a better
Hyperion than you that'd be hilarious
hey uh hey Rob did you see man thing in
the werewolf By Night trailer if not
check screen Geeks yeah Nick um they
actually updated it on that on that
Twitter account on discussing film I
didn't I didn't catch it initially
um but it is cool to see it was cool to
see so uh yeah man thing that's gonna be
awesome
no updates for five minutes
uh
Thunderbolts
are they announcing Thunderbolts news
because the Thunderbolts would be cool
they've literally got no updates here
if we didn't get fan faster Fantastic
Four stuff we sure you don't think we're
gonna be getting X-Men stuff come on you
got to think positive think positive
X-Men and Deadpool X-Men and Deadpool
with d23 for Echo
okay
here's something off your od23 for Echo
okay that's cool that's cool
I could definitely see that
foreign
that's awesome
I'm sorry I'm just still getting the
crack out of uh
having that color of this page
I'm just still getting I'm just so
cracking out over it I'm just cracking
up over it
it's still it's just it's just funny to
me
okay
um
come on X-Men Deadpool
X-Men or Deadpool
come on discussing film get it together
good Lord
Daredevil born again okay
okay so dude I wonder I wonder if
they've got a trailer for it and it
better not be a freaking
exclusive I'm gonna be so pissed off of
this exclusive trailer okay dear double
content Daredevil stuff okay Daredevil
stuff nipple gay 2022 yes
yeah who cares about Echo right now the
only Echo I want to hear about is Echo
of the 90s X-men theme lasting at d23
full volume yeah I mean I don't care
about Echo like Echoes she's in the
comics I don't really care about echo in
the comics
so
uh new logo for Daredevil born again
okay that's awesome that's awesome that
logo looks cool
there's probably Charlie Cox talking
about how awesome irritable it is and
it's going to be a great adventure a
great experience doing it you know doing
that whole thing
so
Jesus we've been live for like two hours
is that how long we've been going for
no three hours holy cow
we've been going for like three hours
Jesus
it's exclusive it's an exclusive trailer
oh it begins filming in 2023 with 18
episodes okay so they haven't even
started filming yet
so they literally have nothing to show
unless they filmed a trailer with
footage they don't have or shot footage
exclusively for a trailer and then like
I said but normally you don't make a
trailer out of you don't normally film
footage exclusively for a trailer and
then start filming the show like you
make a trailer out of the material you
already have so
okay so Daredevil born again okay that's
cool all right X-Men and Deadpool X-Men
and Deadpool
X-Men and Deadpool
Charlie Cox says he's excited to start
filming I started start again with
Daredevil with double the amount of time
yeah I'm so excited for that too I'm
really I'm really hyped about that too
like I'm really hyped about that too
that's gonna be amazing also again make
sure you guys subscribe to the channel
make sure you guys because we're we're
gonna like after this we're gonna do
whole Easter eggs from the trailers that
did come out do breakdowns to the
footage or at least explanations of the
footage and stuff that's basically been
talked about that was exclusive to
um to uh d23 and like we're just we're
gonna make a meal out of all this stuff
over the course of the next few right
we're gonna we're gonna be feasting on
this for a little while so make sure you
guys subscribe to the channel make sure
you guys drop a like make sure you got
your life and again make sure you guys
also check out our Discord server Tony
if you will make a link to the Discord
server that'd be phenomenal that'd be
fantastic
uh
okay
a clip of Charlie Cox's return as
Daredevil and She-Hulk oh okay so
they're showing the clip okay they're
probably not going to show it outside of
d23 because literally the episode comes
out next week so it's probably going to
be in a week it's probably going to be
Wednesday's episode or Thursday's
episode whatever it is it'll be the
episode next week that we'll actually
get to see Daredevil otherwise they
wouldn't release it this close they
would they would wait a little while I
would think
I would say so
uh
Netflix Daredevil is one of the greatest
shows ever yeah okay so here's a
question which season of Daredevil was
better season one or season two
because I still I still say season one
or season two was better than season one
season one had some cool moments but
season two was better
and season two is definitely better
new logo for Captain America New World
Order okay so they're not they're
probably not gonna show the clip from
Daredevil it's going to be exclusive to
d23
I'm excited for Captain America New
World Order
that's going to be a pool that's going
to be a cool
that's gonna be cool okay
God
give us some updates man
season two was the best yeah I thought
season two was the best yeah
you know season three was just boring
season three was so boring to me
Tim Blake Nelson will return as the
leader in Captain America new world
order as the main villain oh perfect
he's a great villain to have pit against
Captain America
you would think it would be an
Incredible Hulk but not really because
because in doing oh dude in doing that
they could introduce the intelligencia
so the intelligencia Marvel Comics were
basically just a group of the smartest
people the smartest villains in Marvel
so it was like a coming together of like
Modoc Doctor Doom um the leader who else
was part of the intelligencia it wasn't
I don't think it was red skull in terms
of like science and technology he was an
idiot but he was really good when it
came to military strategy
um who were the leader who are the
members of the intelligencia guys
uh
who are the leaders of the intelligencia
refresh the damn food
that needs to become uh that needs to
become like a meme or something like
that refresh the damn feed right that
needs to become a meme
uh Carl lumbly will return is Isaiah
Bradley yes
oh my God yes okay how much do you want
to bet they're gonna go deeper into
weapons plus how much do you how much
how much do you want to bet weapons plus
is gonna be a part of this
weapons plus is going to be a part of
this whole thing which if it is it's
becoming more I think it's becoming I
Wolverine into the MCU it's actually
coming to fruition the more the more I
look at that the more it looks like the
more it looks like it is which it would
be awesome if somebody at Marvel Studios
was kind of like hey like this guy's got
a great idea for how we bring in
Wolverine let's steal it and I'll just
be like whatever man like I can say I
had the like I can say you guys
literally got the idea for me because
I've got like three or four videos that
are uploaded explaining that explaining
that whole thing so that'd be super
excited
I'd be super excited about that
but yeah
yeah that would be absolutely nuts
uh
God that would be crazy
Jonas Ona describes Captain America new
world order as a paranoid Thriller oh
God that's gonna be cool how in the hell
is that even gonna play out though
like how does that even play out
like what does that even look like
like I'm curious right I'm curious man
Jesus we've got like 8 000 people
watching this live stream right now
that's Bonkers we've got so many people
watching this stream
you could see Dwayne Johnson as Wonder
Man Henry Cavill is Vulcan Jason Statham
is Gladiator Jason Momoa is Sabertooth
and Terry Crews is Jubilee what now
you're just trolling now you're just
trolling
okay let's update this let's update this
okay no updates yet no more updates yet
okay here we go Donnie Ramirez returns
as the new Falcon in Captain America New
World Order okay so Sam Wilson is
staying Captain America that makes sense
but Sam Wilson is like staying Captain
America he's getting his own Falcon now
here's the question all right here's the
question do you guys think that they
will replace Sam Wilson as Captain
America
in the in the yeah you guys were out
here yeah we out here man do you guys
think they're gonna replace Sam Wilson
as Captain America in the MCU
they'll replace them with a different a
different person to play Captain America
Bucky Barnes or somebody like that
or do you think he's going to stay
Captain America presumably forever
like what do you guys think
[Music]
what do you guys think I'm kind of
curious
no
hmm
okay come on give us give us something
man give us something
some kind of an update man Jesus
at least through uh the Multiverse Saga
wow
okay so most people are saying no
most people are like no they're not
going to replace Sam Wilson as Captain
America maybe in 10 to 20 years but you
you think he's he he is the Captain
America now like he's the guy there's
nobody else who's going to play Captain
America besides him like you think
that's how it is in the MCU now
hmm
that's gonna be interesting
come on give us an update man
discussing film you're losing my
attention
see what Marvel's saying
latest
as a secret Invasion trailer
do we want to take the risk of looking
at somebody else's looking at a
different Twitter feed
do you want to take that risk
last time we did it man we uh
we basically we basically bet on a fart
official artwork for Marvel's
Thunderbolts starring Florence Pugh and
Sebastian Stan okay that's cool
so I don't I mean are we have they even
started filming yet I don't even think
they started filming the trailer or
filming the the
the feeling in the movie
or TV yeah the movie yet
uh
the MCU DM sure
God man they're just parroting what
other people say
uh let's see
go to Murphy's Multiverse okay
um
or if he's
multi oh my God
I can't spell
Murphy's Multiverse oops top
uh
okay
the cast of The Thunderbolts minus pug
did say hi okay so discussing film
they're just really really slow they're
not really the number one source for
quick information they're moderately
reasonable moderately fast information
but they're definitely slow
uh
d23 Thunderbolt lineup revealed
including the Black Widow cast Bucky and
more
okay they're trying to take us off site
that's not gonna happen
okay
nerd erotic
yeah give us Deadpool like give us
Deadpool
so is that hold on is that Taskmaster
hold on this right here
so that I wonder if that's the actual
task master so that's that's my question
was Taskmaster the Taskmaster project
the one from like the the
Whatchamacallit but this if it is man
this is cool man so we get Tony Masters
God this is gonna be a great movie
that's gonna be a great movie holy cow
that roster is legit which I'm so glad
you're seeing they're doing something
with ghost I'm so glad to see they're
doing that
what a terrible cast for the
Thunderbolts that's ridiculous
that is a ridiculous statement and
you're ridiculous for making it like
that's an absolutely amazing cat
wow oh we're getting we're getting the
Bots we're getting the
we're getting the spam Bots that YouTube
won't fix
we're getting the spam Bots that
YouTube's too lazy to fix
okay
any dancing Zemo
comes out next July
okay huge care a huge cheers for
Sebastian Stan who joins a team of
thunderbolts as the Winter Soldier who
feige says is the most stable shoots
next year okay
that comes out next July
wait so Thunderbolts comes out in July
like July of 2020 3 or 2024 because they
haven't started shooting yet
I mean they better get on that they got
like a month or two
it shoots next year so I guess it comes
out 2024.
because I don't I know they announced it
in phase six but I don't remember where
the lineup was
you think it's a boring roster
I mean no it's it's gonna be awesome
it's gonna be legit
uh
the fastest updates are Matt Ramos are
you saying that because he does are you
saying that because you're a Matt Ramos
fan because Matt's cool
but I also know how fan I know I know
how like hardcore fans could be because
people will be like Rob's the best
YouTuber ever in the history of the
world no matter what anybody says and
it's like not really
uh like I'm I'm cool and I love what I
do but you know I'm not the greatest of
all time like it just kind of depends on
who you like the most so
the end of phase five okay
Zemo is Task Master like he was citizen
V in the comics oh okay is that what
they're doing
no I'd want to see I'd want to see like
I want to see actually Tony Masters
all the Marvel's on stage oh I wonder if
they're gonna March out and they're
gonna be like actually there's a member
that we forgot to tell you guys about
and it's gonna be like
it's it's going to be
Adam Brashear
and what if that's gonna happen
because that would be cool but the
Marvels dude I'm I'm so excited for
Marvel's I am so excited about that I
mean Brie Larson not so nobody cares
about Brie Larson but like everybody
else is going to be awesome I'm really
excited for that it's gonna be cool
yeah regardless okay
yeah do you guys think we're gonna get
Blue Marble
um I hope they don't try to do the
suicide squad that might have been
lightning in a bottle
um with his gun yes but Marvel Studios I
don't know
that's a good question to ask
you know I don't know
do you want to see Denzel Washington
play yeah that's a good question that's
a good question Tony
you love Brie Larson Red Hulk uh or
World War Hulk as the villain oh
I would say Red Hulk
I would definitely say Red Hulk
I would love to see Red Hulk but I don't
know if they can do Red Hulk now because
uh
uh yeah because
is it is it William Hurt or John Hurt
I always get him confused but the guy
who plays uh Thunderbolt Ross basically
passed away
and he died so yeah no there's no uh
you could I mean you could do that but I
don't know I guess I guess the the
chicks on the stage are just kind of
rambling for a little while like you're
just rambling about stuff
um so there's no updates yet
but yeah it's a really fun project and I
had a great time doing it yeah like the
models is gonna be amazing you know and
I'm Brie Larson trying to stay relevant
so I'm trying to get people to care
about me so
um and not piss off the whole crew of
like the Avengers film do you guys
remember when those reports were coming
out that like like it was like ree
Larson was there like at the uh on like
Avengers and people were just like yeah
like we're not yeah William Hurt they're
like yeah we're not really feeling
really Larson like she just doesn't fit
in you know and it's just like none of
the cast liked her and then like the fan
like the movie was just not hit not a
hit with fans and so it's just like I
mean
you know like what's going on you know
yeah John Hurt okay John Hurt was an
Indiana Jones yeah
but it was it was wild it was it was
wild
okay
no no update yet
but she just couldn't catch a break like
it just it seemed like nobody liked her
it was like it just seemed like nobody
liked her at all
uh
what if they brought Sam Elliott back
for Thunderbolt Ross uh
Sam Elliott
when did what did Sam Elliott play
Thunderbolt Ross all right let's check
out Matt Ramos
um
right after the post-credits scene of
Miss Marvel okay
Monica Rambo is being trained by Nick
Fury damn you guys are right like he's
updating quick
Monica's suit looks great damn you guys
are right man
or like literally he's just like boom
boom boom that's what we were doing at
San Diego he's doing the exact same
thing we were doing
the Marvel's footage is being shown
Matt Ramos man this dude's got it on
lock
uh
yeah you guys are right man
the Marvel Studios panel is over no uh
so we got we didn't get Deadpool we
didn't get X-Men it's just like updates
to things we already know about oh my
God
so I wonder if they're going to save it
until San Diego of next year
if they're gonna if they're gonna do it
in the Hall of age of San Diego next
year
I wonder if that's when they're gonna do
it
oh no that sucks all right that's the
Marvel Studios panel guys
yeah it looks like the panel's over
let's let's double check let's let's
double check
discussing film
um
let's see yeah they're they're there
deserve the official logo
all right guys yep that looks like
that's the Marvel Studios panel
you feel like Brie Larson is a perfect
Captain Marvel since they are both
equally unlikable
that's amazing all right guys uh yeah so
make sure you guys hit uh make sure you
guys hit the like button make sure you
guys uh subscribe thank you guys for
coming out to the stream this was a
blast but that's the end of the Marvel
Studios panel I guess there's a fox
panel but honestly we've been streaming
for three hours I think I'm kind of
ready to call it a day
um but yeah thanks for coming out guys
so we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up
we're gonna get to work on creating
content for you all we're getting to
work to creating content for you all and
uh yeah so
yeah make sure you guys hit the
Subscribe button and um we will catch
you all later
peace